what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame everyone clap yeah uh before
I start don't forget to subscribe to the
channel and bring that notification Bell
the way you're gonna be notified of my
daily videos like the video on your way
and make sure you subscribe to our two
clips channels just pearly clips and
pearl daily today we have a lovely cast
um so to start we're gonna go around
everyone say your name your age
relationship status and a fun fact about
yourself starting here and then go
around
hey my name is Zarina matcha I'm an
author and I'm 26 years old and I'm just
really happy to be here thank you
yeah yeah yeah hi my name is and I'm 20
years old single and
um
are my teeth white enough oh cool yeah
hi my name is Candy G I'm the founder of
evolve Nation Academy currently touring
the evolved Nation women in Creative
industry Summit I turned 40 yesterday
and
I'm single slash widowed kind of thing
yeah does he know yet
yeah he died two years ago okay I mean
you said you said slash so I'm like is
this in the words yeah I didn't know how
to word it yeah
40 you look young I didn't really thank
you very much go ahead hey I'm Dimitri
I'm the CEO of lgfg fashion house the
suit company that makes all those famous
suits
um lgbg.com I'm 40 also I look okay for
40. I think maybe but uh maybe and you
said it was on your birthday yesterday
yeah so that's congratulations my
daughter's birthday is today so before I
jump on the plane today oh that's nice
oh sorry
anyways 40 I got a a wife and four kids
oh that's nice impressive I know I know
I forgot to say my relationship state of
single
so today's today's topic is is feminism
topic or is feminism toxic so question
for the panel do you think that feminism
is toxic yes or no and tell me why
starting here and then go around yes
feminism is absolutely toxic it's
completely terrible for society it's
destroying man it's destroying women I
think it's probably one of the worst
things to happen to male and female
relationships so yeah absolutely agree
I don't know I think I'm 50 50 I think
it's good for us females to
I don't know I don't know
I don't know I don't want to say
something and then
people don't agree with me but it's okay
it's okay I'll we we allow all
disagreements on the show so it's okay
there are no wrong answers
um
I would just say it's 50 50. okay but
it's 64. if you had to pick one side
um
yeah okay yeah you do think it's toxic
yeah it's very toxic okay 100 what do
you think yeah I think it's toxic I
think it breaks down the family unit and
I also think it impacts Society in a
negative way
as a uh as a man identifying as a woman
to compete in women's sports I think
it's great uh it has really increased my
athletic performance relative to my
competition
and I'm looking forward to being called
stunning and brave
um but in all seriousness I mean
any ideology probably starts out at some
point with some positive attributes that
are necessary for for society right
um but
like every ideology eventually becomes
weaponized and I think right now we're
living in a world where you ladies are
acknowledging it as well which is very
strange for a woman to say that like oh
you know feminism talks like because
you're a woman you should be like Yay
feminism right so I think we're starting
to come around as a society and
realizing that there's a there's a
certain ideological weaponization where
feminism went from empowering women to
just [__] on men
and that's uh that's a bad line
okay well when do you think feminism is
ever empowering for women
that's a great question do you want to
go like a historical argument or where
are we going for this yeah yeah when uh
okay so so there's there's like kind of
an interesting
there's obviously this is such a
granular argument like there's so many
flavors to this it's not like an
outright you know you know and I don't
want to be like sounding like oh I'm not
going to take a position like I have a
position right like for example
um
my mom is a computer scientist as an
example right like she's very
intelligent she went all the way through
the school got her Masters in PhD
whatever she got
um and so she she performed she just
retired like this month but she
performed at a very high level a very
male dominated industry and frankly
she's not a very feminine woman so like
the opportunity for her to go all the
way in her education which was a math
and computer science and then
implemented that for her career was very
beneficial for her like she would not
fit the mold of a woman that is in a in
a let's say more controlled Society
where that might have not been an option
right because she's not a good housewife
she was a terrible wife then what does
that have to do with feminism what does
her success have to do with family well
so so you're I understand what you're
saying so when you go back to like for
example one of the stem countries right
now where maybe 15 20 years ago women
were not allowed to get an education
above let's say the fourth or fifth
grade level and you might say fine but I
would say okay at that point you need it
to push it a little bit further right
like if you have to tell girls you're a
writer right we had a conversation
before we started you're smart like you
know things you quoted Aldous Huxley I'm
like ah she reads yeah but what's that
what to do with feminism wouldn't you
put that down to somebody's individual
merits right in that person well the
original the original premise behind
feminism we're going back a couple
hundred years here was that women were
allowed to substantially be educated as
much as men because certain religions
let's say forbade women from getting a
higher level education like they were
not even allowed to read under most sort
of the archaic religions right so there
was a time there was a time where and
that was a you know a while ago there
was a time where you would not have been
able to have been an author and you
think of what time period was about
because I know in the U.S like well
we've at least in the 1600s there was
girls getting who's Tia who's Tia is
that is that the author that's actually
a woman but pretended to be a man
because she couldn't get her books
published as a woman so there was a very
long-standing history that women could
not publish books so like look I'm not
yeah I've seen I know at least 17 1800s
like women were published
um like they could write they were in
like the Wall Street Journal like that
whatever the there's a couple
Publications that were still no no no
look look here let me let me explain
this like like this is we can we can we
can take this even further to the racism
argument it's like okay there's there's
nobody wants slavery it's horrible and
it's like the most absurdly horrible
thing that's ever happened and it's
happened to you know in different
societies and then you go to like all
the way to the other side in affirmative
action where it's like well I don't
really want that either even though it's
supposedly like anti-discriminatory
becomes discrimination right so feminism
like at its core it didn't start out
with nefarious intent of like completely
disagree if you go back to so for
example the 1848 uh Seneca Falls
Convention you'll find that actually
right from the get-go feminism is always
very very misandrick very very awful
just a very soon
on the Titanic 70 of women survived
80 uh
25 of men survived yeah and the
feminists were like if a woman built the
ship we would have did it better wait
they don't have for some reason is never
it's a big misconception because a lot
of people think feminism was once good
but actually this is a lie and if you
look at his stories
I agree I agree with it ideologically it
was it was misag it was the Karl Marx
kind of a situation I know 100 it
started no 100 but but here's can I ask
you a question I mean and I can't
believe I'm taking the side by the way
but it's like
would you be okay if if women were not
allowed to go past the third grade
education in the society in which you
live well the thing is yes
yes telling you College makes you dumber
I'm not drawing the line of college we
can get there I'm sorry I'm starting
third grade the thing is is that the
misconception here is that the main
inequalities in society were actually
more to do with class rather than gender
because for example a wealthy woman
would have had much more social
privilege than a poor man and women
actually could be educated for example
during medieval England a lot of women
works and us saying they worked in
teaching so this idea that somehow women
couldn't be educated I mean if you just
look at the West for example this isn't
true actually education was more
reserved for the upper classes and it's
always been that way even things like
property ownership as well it's not
really the feminist has made it as a men
versus women thing but it was never the
case it was more about class so I mean I
think you're referring to her because I
know you're referred to specifically to
like religious countries I'm not going
to comment on that but right now but if
we just look at say the west or England
education opportunities have always been
there but they've been referred they've
been on what wrong word reserved for the
wealthier classes and the feminist lie
affects is that oh this was about men
oppressing women but it wasn't it was
more about the upper classes were the
ones who held more of the privilege in
society so you know and women women you
know they did things like sewing
needlework music things like nursing a
lot of women worked as Governor says so
it is a big misconception that women
couldn't work or that women couldn't
have careers or that women weren't
educated a lot of these are very big
misconceptions no but what they do is
they rewrote the history you probably
know yes
they went back all the marxists went
back and basically said we want to look
at history from the Viewpoint of the
oppressed yeah so they literally went
back in the history books and rewrote
the history from the vantage point of an
oppressed woman even though the women of
the writings at the time not a press
well they none of them were Rich how did
feminism like overtake as a movement it
was female-led so it's like how did they
have the voice if they had no voice or
education it's very erotic these were
the most privileged women in society if
you look at especially the old school
first wave feminist people
yeah isn't that the one that like
divorced her husband took all his money
it was terrible all of them they were
always apart from the get-go it was a
very mean-spirited very antagonistic
movement and the problem is is that a
lot of people don't understand this it's
like it's nobody's fault it's the fact
that for example people will say oh look
at the suffragettes but because they've
heard all the women's studies professors
in the school yes and then they re they
all they even said this themselves
they're gonna rewrite our history and
then teach it in the schools to
brainwash the kids and get rid of
religion they did the same thing in the
church so they went into the Christian
churches the Catholic churches why do
you think there's all those gay priests
right it was because they literally sent
11 000 priests into the church because
they realized that people listen to the
church and yeah it's it's Rabbit Hole
when you get into it but the crazy thing
is they literally said we want to
infiltrate these institutions because we
know people listen to them I mean a lot
of these priests rules are beautiful 100
no
11 they funded the seminaries to again
to re-teach education from a more like
the Christian doctrine from a more
liberal point of view Yeah
well yeah yeah Marxist I think American
liberalism is a shame isn't it because
actually classical English liberalism is
completely anti-moxic it's a really
terrible thing how like in America like
your version of liberalism is what we
would call like yeah yeah but it's all
your fault as well like that's another
like you know language barrier or
whatever kind of a pain in the butt
really so what I thought was interesting
okay this is what I wanted to do I
wanted to talk about the wives before
feminism and after feminism so I I
collaborated with Dr David Baker shout
out he wrote the history of sex and I
wanted to compare the wives of yesterday
like what you would get out of a wife a
hundred years ago 200 years ago versus
what you get out of a wife today and I
wanna I it's you know I want to compare
and contrast so one
she would not leave you so if you
married her it was highly unlikely she
would leave divorce was extremely
difficult to obtain as opposed to today
if you multiply the divorce rate by the
percent the woman leave there's a 32 to
41 percent chance that she's going to
leave you thank you feminism two two
depending on the time period or social
class your wife would help out on the
farm doing hard work beside you like
planting seeds dealing with livestock
helping out the Harvest and at least
she'd be a housewife in both scenarios
you'd be dealing with cooking from
scratch
um
and putting a hot lot of work into
cleaning and laundry no domestic
technology so we'll put on this side
today you get like microwave dinner but
it's not
a smokes this is a shame like there's
plenty of good women it's just the
problem is that the feminists have kind
of made like women look bad well I would
say this is what I'll say about it
95 percent of us would be thrown out
because one of the prerequisites back
then was a virgin and today only five
yeah who wants isn't that a bit outdated
like I don't think so I don't think I
think men would prefer their wife to
have only slept with them as opposed to
multiple men why is the issue yeah
exactly yes but what about men yeah
that's a big double sign actually it's
about two days it's a biological
standard you guys want some stats on
this because yeah give them the stuff
I'll give you guys some statistics so
today it's four percent of women that
are marrying as virgins right here's
something really four percent we're not
even at five no it's four percent okay
guys okay so here I'll give you guys
some interesting stats and there's a
there's a there's like a fee like let's
say a common theme to all of these to
kind of converge onto a point but
um in the 1950s the birth control pill
comes out right we now have obviously
fewer women marrying off his virgins
than before I dropped like the amount of
women that were marrying as virgins in
the in the 50s have dropped to like down
to four percent it wasn't like 80 now
it's like four percent interesting five
percent 100 years ago what's really
interesting is since the 1950s the
percentage of men that are marrying as
virgins is actually higher than it was
in the 50s
so what happened with the birth control
pill is that it basically took out all
the it just it just streamlined all the
sex to the guys that the women wanted to
do it with the whole time and without
consequence so that's an interesting
outcome but when you're looking at the
the marriage that this looks okay there
are two predictors for that stand above
all else for an uh three producters
actually the stand above all else for
poor outcome to the marriage like an
unsuccessful bad breakup poor marriage
unhappiness number one getting married
before the societal standard age so if
you're married like 18 you're gonna fail
it's gonna suck don't do it number two
if a woman brings a child into the
relationship into the marriage that's
not the man's child is a extremely high
productive for the woman's unhappiness
in that marriage not the man's
unhappiness the woman's own unhappiness
which inevitably leads to divorce
because about 80 percent of marriages
are divorces are initiated by women the
third factor and this is really really
interesting the third Factor today
that's the highest correlated
statistically with the poor outcome to
the marriage is the woman has more than
10 sexual partners so what happens is
the biggest dropped for women's in a
man's happiness in the marriages after
the woman has one sexual partner you see
the biggest drop in the happiness and
the potential positive outcome in the
marriage and then like between two and
five it kind of like hovers you know
where it was a two and then between like
six and nine it kind of gets a little
bit worse but a 10 or more the drop the
drop is significant and massive and this
is just this is just measuring you know
longitude in those studies of the
happiness and the outcomes of the
marriage but here's what's interesting
then they did the same study on men
number of sexual partners that a man has
and then correlated that to the outcome
of the marriage no statistical
correlation at all a man because men
don't leave marriages women do that's
why so you don't think it's actually
because of sex is because women are just
more likely to leave well men don't so
so it's like this if a man said if he's
Genghis Khan level he's got a thousand
Partners it has no statistical
difference in the outcome of a marriage
of a man's had three Partners it just
doesn't like that's just what the
statistics say interesting right and so
women are like well why do men get the
privilege because biologically we're
different from women and I think that's
a premises I mean historically they had
to make sure that the kid was theirs
yeah and they're saying like what 10 20
of men today are raising a kid that's
not theirs yeah
it's it's one out of three if you have
out of men that and it depends on the
study you look at bad of men that get it
tested it's one out of three years so
it's like one in fifty man yeah well I
mean it depends what you look at but I
mean they think it's higher it would be
really interesting to see if they did
mandatory paternity tests birth I would
guess it would go up
um but yeah I mean I mean you guys know
the sun innate level men don't like
Horrors right but don't you I mean we
shouldn't be shaming women because
actually when we say the women are
[__] what we're actually doing is
we're buying into this very reductive
like virgin good girl bad girl dichotomy
which comes from Christianity
sorry I don't don't think is that we're
shame in women you kind of are though
because actually I think I've been
around sleeping with any who and
everyone who's calling we are going to
look at you and be like you're a ho e
doesn't mean we're shame it doesn't mean
we're shaming ladies who's like trained
women men or women
well actually women it's women it's
women it's it's women and it's not close
and do you know why women are the ones
it's the women that are saying you're
such you know why women do it it's not
jealousy no no I'm busy
I'll put myself in their shoes and I
think I look at them and I think no
you're right okay I'll tell you guys Why
women's live stream women
because women control acts the sexual
Marketplace it's women that decide who
gets to have sex and if a woman's giving
it away easily it actually devalues
yourself in the market because a man can
get it from her so it's women what if
people just want to have fun people can
have all the fun they want but but it's
not the mandatory I mean you can have
fun it's just they probably won't pick
you for a wife later well it depends on
the kind of guy you go with because
I wouldn't want to go with a guy who
wanted a version I'll give you I'll give
you an example 90 of men would
disqualify a girl just based off of only
fans
called a guy who thinks like that I
don't know I can tell you why that's
biologically yeah
I go home there's only friends to their
mum I would never if I was a man
someone would look at me and be like
what if she wants money yeah
I think what if she's trying to make a
living then go to McDonald's
that's the easy way out only fans is the
easy way out the people that are lazy
and I don't want to work that's the
greatest of it no it is it is because
what are you doing you're flashing your
body so for some money what's wrong with
that there's nothing wrong to do yeah
but obviously we we've all got our own
opinions and that's just here's a I'm
gonna give you guys something I think we
should bring back shame I think we
should change
because because women women respond
really well to social yes yes they do
women women are very easy to propagate
they learn this in the 20s when they put
rate like when they started using like
radio to influence women like we women
are very easily influencers why we all
have the latest fashion trends the
latest makeup trends like women go with
the trends and the thing is when the
trend is whoredom that's not that
doesn't make good wives and mothers
wouldn't you say that the sexual
Revolution then was caused by the
absolute obsession with female virginity
and it's almost like if you have this
Upstream you end up going from one
extreme to the other I would say that
the sexual Revolution was caused by
birth control and women wanting to be
[__] when you think about it guys
feminism let us do anything
to do how crazy is that we could have
chosen anything we could have been
astronauts
we could have like went to the moon we
started a Fortune 500 companies you know
I mean
I mean it shows
follow the rules just oh sorry you just
keep cutting in and interrupting no
worries my my apologies women women
could have did anything and we chose
whoredom that and that's the funny thing
85 percent of us were virgins a hundred
years ago now now
95 of us aren't that's how much we go
with Trends so a little shame I think
it's not a bad thing
so this is really fast I'm writing a
book right now it's called The Book of
Shame oddly enough but yeah yeah um and
it's gonna have and I'm and I've been
very very deep into it for a few months
now it's going to have a leather cover
and like energy crystals on the cover
but um there's a really interesting
argument that uh sort of self-revealed I
I didn't expect this to happen but I
started looking into it it's like okay
statistically I can say yes like there's
very clear data and it's like
irrefutable and it's been replicated
many times through many studies that if
a woman's got 10 or more sexual partners
the outcome of that marriage is going to
be very very poor like relative to other
marriages like it's just it's um but the
question is like but why but why and
then I stumble upon this one study and
then it led me to another study and I've
collected like seven pages of data from
different studies on this and it's
always convergent on the same factor and
here's the question this one's a
mind-blowing thing so pay attention okay
is promiscuity
a choice or is it a genetic
predisposition
it's an interesting question like we
want to say okay let's just say we think
it's a it's a it's it's a it's a choice
right we want to say it's a choice you
know you can be like that you're having
fun okay but now watch this I'm gonna
give you guys an anecdotal example and
I'll give you some statistics and it
gets really weird okay when you think of
a single mother like just imagine a
single mom and she's got a kid
okay you got it is that kid male or
female
is it a little girl she's raising or a
little boy
I don't know why I see a male it's
always a little boy right we always say
oh it's a little boy that's not by
accident okay that's not there's a very
that's not by accident this gets really
interesting right so there's uh there's
a ribosome a sequence of ribosomes in
the genes uh that when it lines up in a
certain in a certain alignment
it has something like a 78 productive
factor of your socio-sexual status
sociosexuality is like a scientific way
of saying promiscuity it's how you treat
sex like you know just socially and not
with any sort of higher purpose right
and it's genetic and what else is crazy
about it is well a couple of things
right number one women that have this
particular set of ribosomes are are more
promiscuous by definition number two
they're more likely to have male
offspring
wow yeah and it's and it's like it's
been known for like 40 years huh why do
you think that's the case there are
reasons there actually are reasons for
it which get very scientific and very
interesting okay this is my guess yeah
this is my guess so back in the day if
you were like a concubine I'd imagine
you'd be a concubine for like the most
like Alpha guy like the king yes so
maybe there's some genetic variation
that happened because the Kings wanted
sons and they would kind of when they
kill the mistresses that like couldn't
give them Suns like wouldn't they this
is just a wild guy I don't know the
answer to that but I know that female
when you know when you have a a girl as
opposed to a boy the sperm just rates
longer in the in the uterus right or in
the going up and through the Fallopian
tubes Etc so it's like
um so there there is an argument to be
said that there's just like a different
kind of sex that occurs when a woman is
very very into the sex which a hyper
sexual woman would be because they
exhibit more male characteristics right
and so one and I started reading into
that and there's like quite and there's
got like a whole chapter on it and as I
as I'm reading through studies and I'm
like I'm putting all this data together
I'm going oh my God maybe there's a
genetic trigger to tell men to stay away
for away from promiscuous women
because they're genetically predisposed
to cheat on you
wow
that's very interesting well can I ask
you a question what's wrong with a woman
being a hole
well I just don't think it makes for
good wives and mothers
but part of being a wife is to enjoy sex
with your husband yeah
your husband and the highest sex
practice perfect no but the highest
sexual satisfaction was when they've
only had sex with one person
so she's gonna enjoy sex more
the number one and the number one piece
and the number one person that women
cheat with is their exes
You could argue that I just don't think
it'd be true I think they would just
make you a [__] well it depends on
someone
because the thing is as well would you
say that people are more likely to be
attracted to people who are like them so
for example a woman who say been with a
few people would want a guy who's also
been with a few people a Man Loves a
[__] they will [__] up but they will
not marry a [__] they will want to find
a lady that hasn't slept with
men a wifey and a wifey isn't someone
that sleeps around for fun and wants to
I don't know build their experience up
go use a toy especially if a man has
resources you look at a country like
France today where paternity testing is
illegal in France you can look this up
you go to jail for 20 years for getting
a paternity test so if the wife delivers
a child that's not the color that you
are it's like you just have to accept
them as your kid and that's it right and
so and now your resources are going to a
man you know to a baby to a child it's
not your child which it's like if you
have resources as a man what are your
what are your chances of preserving
those in divorce court like pretty damn
close to zero zero benefits happy razor
loser kids though uh more children great
so find a man that's Happy raising other
men why wouldn't he just get a young
woman that can give him a bunch of kids
what if he's got five young women who
can give him a bunch of kids
not my baby dad
I mean I mean you'd probably be
attracted to a man that has those
options okay we're gonna go back to the
wives of yesterday from today okay
so we're just gonna go through so what
do we say before she would stay 85
percent of people were married there was
a big social stigma against divorce now
there's a 32 to 41 percent chance she's
leaving your ass yeah okay
pipe down wait okay thank you all right
so depending on the time period in
social class you'd have a wife helping
up on the farm so you're gonna get some
cooking from scratch right
and farming now I'm not saying there are
not wives that offer this but does the
average chick I don't know how to farm
you guys know how to farm he does you
know I I don't know how to farm
I'm not a perfect person I don't know I
do help my dad water the garden but
that's about how fast I how far I take
it okay so we got cooking and farming
then then three there was a major stigma
against female cheating you wouldn't
have to worry about her cheating on you
it happened but so infrequently that it
would barely cross your mind as opposed
to today where one in five women cuck
their partners
right there yes okay next four rule of
thumb is a myth
um Christian cultures always despise
wife beating and the paranoia about
domestic violence was not as high as
today meaning if your wife attacked you
you could defend yourself as opposed to
today where half of domestic violence is
reciprocal seventy percent of
non-recipro the wife is beating on you
sometimes with a weapon and the cops get
called the man is the one getting
arrested so they used to be able to well
I should I put this on the wrong one you
could call the police on your girl and
they would help you if she starts
beating you okay
so
um if the wife left which was unlikely
she could not take your kids from you
unless you gave them up voluntarily so
the father automatically got custody
where today
ninety percent of the time woman
gets
kids
okay
next
in most cases when you married a woman
you would get a dowry from her family
any any of you come with a dowry no no I
know dang it right it's like
a dollar what I can give you a dollar
wow thank you I actually I do come with
eight acres of land shout out dad but
uh but
um it may it made sense since you were
the one providing financially seven she
would be a virgin
moreover it would it would pipe down all
right wait we'll get to you it was
considered her wifely duty to have sex
with you so Unlimited
sorry guys I did not make this very good
chart unlimited sex
sure she might deny you sex but sexless
marriages were a lot less common where
now one in four marriages
are sexless
very different as the head of the
household you'd have the final say on
all major decisions if your wife
disagreed with you she'd have to consult
privately and not disagree with you
publicly oh King I'm sorry I did not
tell you this before can you pull up the
tweet that I have the the muzzle I'm
gonna you know go on my Twitter go on my
Twitter and look for a picture you'll
know it you'll know it I said should we
bring this back okay I'm gonna I'm gonna
go to ten I'm gonna skip nine I'm gonna
go back in terms of child care and
domestic cleaning there would be no
question of 50 50 on top of your job
just because your wife wanted to be a
dental hygienist or receptionist because
some feminist teacher told her it was
important NADA she was a stay-at-home
wife 11. women were expected to behave
gracefully and look after their
appearance not to mention post-modern
period obesity was a lot rarer because
of high food scarcity and lack of junk
food so she was in shape now
unfortunately today we're a hundred and
seventy pounds
I think you guys are a little thinner
I'm American you know what I mean
um I'm so but it's like 160. regardless
we're both fat UK US
um women were expected to learn to learn
how to sing or play an instrument
um to help pass the hours with evening
entertainment So Not only would you get
a girl that could Farm make food from
scratch she also had to play an
instrument and sing for all of your
friends she had to trust you to make the
final decision 13 she'd take your last
name none of this hyphen I want to keep
my own name all right 14. she'd be
raised to think marriage motherhood and
duty to her husband was her purpose in
life rather than motherhood being
optimal a burden and having to delete
the word Obey from oh my God they
deleted the word Obey from wedding vows
I don't even know that all right 15.
because uh people courted and then Mary
didn't play the field monogamy was
strictly enforced you can forget about
this modern 80 20 thing the modern
gorilla-like quasi-polygamy where fours
are chasing dudes who are tens was gone
most men provided they were mentally
stable not criminals could find a wife
even if you were beta AF you would you
would not be invisible some women out
there would consider you a prospect
moreover women had to look for traits
that made a good husband that healthy
good quality gentlemanly traits a modern
woman find boring today you would this
guy's funny um you wouldn't have to
learn to be cocky mildly cruel
borderline sociopath just to keep a
woman's interest no leaving her on red
for six hours you want to bring her
flowers because you like her odds are
she'd actually appreciate it 16 as a
result of the smallness of the dating
pool in the local Village and the
emphasis on choosing a man who's a good
provider and had the traits of being
sensible caring husband a distinctly mid
5 out of 10 guy had a good shot at a
hottie as opposed to the results of
dating apps over half of dating now
where the men often end up with a woman
significantly
uglier than them and fatter than them
hey do you know the stats that's really
interesting so I got one more and I need
you to wait one more so this is my
favorite one did you find it King all
right there was a social stigma against
women who nagged or yelled too much or
berated their husband in England they
called this a scold and there were laws
against it and you could be
punished by public shaming or forcing a
woman to wear a muzzle which show them
yeah so if you nagged your husband too
much
I asked the guy should we bring this
back you know I just wanted to see
scroll down scroll down I don't I don't
even know what they said
let's see so
that was the quality of the wives then
so do you think feminism has made us
better women overall do you know what
following hearing your stats and even
seeing that muzzle
um I still have my views on feminism but
I would say that it has played a huge
part in
um assisting women you know with getting
a better quality of life I get more
equality because it obviously at some
point there was a lot of Oppression and
I don't think there were treatment I
don't think it was oppression ever
yeah
um I believe so and um I believe that
you know to a certain point that is
assisted like just creating a bit of
space letting getting our voices heard
because like it's all well saying that
we don't agree with a lot of the things
that the feminists say today the reason
why I don't agree with them is because
they're taking it too far and like the
definition is being lost of Independence
on what it is to be an independent woman
and person but as far as feminism and
what the people were doing to make the
change and the changes I think that to a
certain extent they are doing a good
thing because it is important that we
have a diverse you know diverse people
and voices on the tables like you've got
a diverse panel you know so it's
important that we can get a Mel's
opinion you know so all voices all
cultures are very important in order for
us to breathe greater Innovation for us
and breathe better humans within our
children in a better future you know I
think I think promise that men and women
can be equal I think is wrong I think
men are yeah but there's equal to what
extent you know so obviously if you're
talking in a sense of relationships then
obviously we can go to traditions and
cultures there's a few different factors
that we can point out if we want to look
it in that way but so I do agree that
there is relative in the home I'm very
traditional in that way I agree with a
lot of the things that um not I don't
agree with all of the things before no
Muzzle I kind of liked the muzzle you
see I'm very um I like I do agree you
know that um again I'm all for diversity
I think voices do need to be heard but
there's respect as well
and a muzzle's very disrespectful well
it was only used it was only used for
extreme women you've seen those women
that are berating their husbands in
public that that make their husbands
lives a living hell it wasn't yeah that
woman was brought up and then nothing
down for the man is an individual to say
that's not the kind of woman I want to
be with well but you were forced to be
married back then so to me I was like
I'm not saying we should bring back the
mo I'm kind of joking but but my my
thing is I kind of understand it because
they were forced in this marriage he's
married to a wicked wife it's like women
don't talk about so like social abuse or
verbal abuse women can be very verbally
abusive and women are equally abusive as
men you get and when men that go Foods
or Mystic violence and because of women
as well so it can work both ways and
again
maybe it doesn't get discussed as much
because obviously in today's culture
today's culture everything has been
changed so feminism has actually brought
and changed laws whereas imagine if
women that a lot of women were getting
domestically abused and nothing was
getting done about it because their
voices weren't being heard there wasn't
laws for them but they even but I was
saying even though but even even back
then they would argue that the the laws
still favored women like for example
they estimate that 61 of murders were
done by women and most of them didn't
even get because back then they didn't
have abortion so women would literally
kill a quarter of their kids they'd just
kill them we're also missing that
there's like a interesting piece of the
puzzle that we're missing in this is
that like okay let's go back to the
1700s and yes like there are some
different sort of expectations so women
are doing all this stuff around the
house Etc but it's like what was the
what was life like for an average man in
the 1700s how horrible right it's like
you're working on something like that
you're breathing poison at work all the
time you're dealing with poison you're
dying like is way shorter for men it was
like farmhand coal miner or a factory
worker but I don't remember what year
the factories came in and like there's a
pretty good chance you're gonna get like
a wound that kills you or you're going
to lose a limit whatever job you're
doing and you're gonna die 10 to 15
years earlier than the woman in your
life so it's like oh we have all these
rules it's like well
man man had a really hard existence back
then right and it's like can you give
him a little credit he's going to die in
war probably defending you well my my
thing is I just think we can't be equal
because every time like how can you have
equality when you always have to appeal
to men to enforce our rights you always
have to ask men to give us the rights
question about this article was this
this is presenting a very overly idyllic
version of the past and a very very like
antagonistic version of the present
because there would have been many women
back then who would have been bad wives
who would have been very cruel to their
husbands and there are many women yeah I
showed you the muzzle
idealistic version because I agree with
you though I completely agree that
feminism is bad but to say that it was
all brilliant back then because for
example as the gentleman rightly said
you know a lot of men let very difficult
lives it's not like I didn't say it I
didn't say it was it's all good I would
argue the wives were better then I mean
I think I think on the basis of Purity
alone yeah
I've had over 600 I probably had a
thousand P women in here in the last
year the majority don't know how to cook
from the society I I have interviewed
women all over the world like yeah
everywhere I'm telling you I've I I
can't even count how many countries
we've had and I'm not saying there are
women that are more traditional that do
cook that do all those traditional
things but do I think more than half of
women have those skills today no well
you don't have to go back far just think
of your grandparents marriage like most
of us can remember our you know our
grandparents being together and what
that marriage looked like and it's
probably different than how our parents
were and it's different from our peers
my mom showed me
I was grown up she looked after my dad
she looked after the family my mom did
not know what working was she was just a
housewife she would cook my dad would
come home from work and we would have a
family dinner that's how it was 19 years
my mom was putting up with it and I
think it's just about how you're raised
it's not about like I don't know it just
really depends on how you're raising I
guess the people you're around literally
being a housewife is a good thing as
well as what we should not housework
well I think my point is if you look at
every statistical data point the wives
are worse today than they were they're
better
yeah just because you just because you
don't like the way it sounds like the
the facts women were more the women were
more pure
I mean modern like we do all the women
are not feminists
they might not identify as a feminist
but most women live their lives
according to feminism because
traditional women put family first but
you don't have so traditional have to be
traditional women are typically married
before the age of 25 because that's the
number one thing they prioritize most
women go to college and college teaches
you to be a feminist I'm not saying it's
women's fault completely right because
we're all told to go to college we're
told to do this stuff but it's like when
you prioritize having a career in your
most fertile years that's the life of a
fact that's causing a career as a
feminist for example
Margaret Thatcher was not a feminist
like you don't isn't the options don't
have to be traditional woman versus
feminism
I'm saying they might not identify as a
feminist but the way they live their
life is more feminist because because
when I said when I say when I say
traditional traditional is putting the
family first if family is your first
priority so women that are truly true
I'm not even saying I'm I'm not a
traditional woman otherwise I'd be
married by now so I'm not even I'm not
even saying it's me but I'm saying the
women I know that are the most feminine
the most traditional they are married
before 25 they don't really care about
college they don't really care about a
career and that's their number one
priority so a lot of times people get
like for like like frustrated because
they're like women think they're
traditional and they're not but why the
options traditional versus feminist you
know like because also this is the
misconception being an independent woman
doesn't mean being a feminist like a lot
of career women because women have took
in it to the to the next level and not
even understanding what it means to be
independent so now a lot of these women
are saying oh I'm independent I don't
need a man
like you can be pro-man and also be a
career focused woman you know what I
mean like there's been a lot of married
women for example Helen garley brown was
happily married and she was one of the
founders of sexual Liberation a lot of
feminists didn't like her okay so what
party's trying to say is it's either
you're going to dedicate your life to
your family
or you're going to dedicate yourself to
a big career no one's saying you can't
No One's Gonna no you can't so basically
I I my my business Academy I actually
train women to do business like women
entrepreneurs and um female leaders yeah
the reason why I do it is not for the
feminists though to preach for them to
be independent but what I'm trying to do
is to help them build their self-esteem
and give them skills that they can
transfer to their children because the
way I see it the women spend the
majority of the time at home with their
children with the children so in order
to build leaders and entrepreneurs out
of our children we need to educate our
women in that way so that's the purpose
of my business so when I'm teaching
these women I'm not teaching them to say
right you are going to go into your
business you're going to be leaders and
you don't need no men you're going to
lead the world I'm not teaching them
that I'm teaching them to grow and be
more confident with themselves and
become better influencers for their
children because as women we are a big
influence in society and to our children
you know but the the misconception that
a lot of these modern day women have is
when they're trying foolishness like we
don't need men in the home we don't need
a man what are you teaching your
daughter yes what are you teaching your
son so do you want your daughter to go
and get breathed by go and sleep with
any man and have five three different
baby dads no you want to teach your
daughter the right way my daughter's
father's died a couple days ago I'm not
looking to just go and get into a
relationship just to have a man around
me I rather make sure that I do it the
right way so I can teach my daughter the
right way you know and there is a
problem with just sleeping around I'm
not going to run up my mileage dating
how many men just to go and pleasure
myself that what's that going to look
like to my child what kind of man would
I be introducing into my life
no it's like so it's not a case of
saying you know there's any to me the
traditional way works that's why our
grandparents were together for so long
you know and this modern day way of
living that's why you've got all these
single mothers growing up Sons on their
own and then their sons are becoming
feminine and they can't even deal with
your daughter they can't even deal with
your daughter properly or be a man to
your grandchild that's why they're
breeding these girls and leaving them
saying got no man in their home because
of these modern day women uneducated
your business sounds amazing but don't
you think we can find a balance between
the traditional and the modern because
there's no need to go back to the 1800s
yeah
so what pearly's trying to say to you is
you've got a choice is I've got a
friendship I know one girl I've got to
know a couple girls like that and
they're actually going up into their 40s
they're deep in their 30s and they
haven't got no children and I actually
feel a bit like sorry for them they've
never really had a serious relationship
and my my thing is it's probably because
you're not really focused you're not
presenting yourself in that way how can
you how can you get a husband if you're
not letting off that energy if you're in
a rave every day if all your friends are
single how are you going to get a
husband if you're sleeping with everyone
what man wants you like seriously
there's a difference what's wrong with
being I hope there's a lot of wrong
being alone you need to respect yourself
to be honest so first and foremost
before getting a man to respect you
because man's Gonna Fill that energy
yeah so if you don't respect yourself no
one else is going to say there's a lot
to do with that and then what are you
going to be feeding to your daughter to
your son or to your nieces or nephews
and this is the problem with modern day
women and not thinking they're not very
conscious about what this they're just
following Trends it's not it's not well
but but the but the the point is it's
still most most women are not
traditional it's like we can't we can't
have a conversation about it we can we
cannot have a conversation about
anything unless we can have
generalizations and we know that over 50
of women I would say are not
marriageable if you ask them men they're
going to say the same exact thing it's
not up to us to decide whose
marriageable it's up to the men yeah
and he's 22 and he's so he made a really
good imprint and going back and he was
saying to me about
um girls his age like he's like that age
group he's like Mom you can't take them
seriously because he's saying the rules
of reverse he said and imagine this is a
guy that's 22 like and nothing he was
about 19 at the time when he told me
this and what his point is is that these
girls they're actually the ones running
down six and man they're the ones you
know the tables they've turned now so
they're like the boys and again
why is that because of these the
education that they're getting from
these goals from the last generation
think about how bad this is four percent
of women are virgins on their wedding
days that is a traditional woman she
waits till she's married four percent we
went from 85 percent to four percent I
can't think of many modern men who are
demanding virginity you know they're not
demanding they're not but they're not
demanding it because they can't how can
they demand it when four percent men
adapt to the market their studies
stop stop there's there's studies
there's studies that have said that that
sex is a need for men yeah and so if sex
is a need they're going to adapt to the
market but most men would prefer a
virgin for a wife there's four billion
men in the world you know this
statistically somebody would prefer it
but I think because of today's culture I
think it's highly unlikely I don't think
people are more advantages of the past I
think people lied no they didn't because
the consequences with sex were real
before the birth control pill like women
were like there was always the men that
women men wanted and then there's the
men that women needed long term and
there's a difference the cat versus that
strategy right the cat is like the Chad
and Tyrone we call him today an
evolutionary psychologist called the cat
or an evolution biology and then there's
the dad which is the long-term partner
right and the problem was the women
couldn't be with those Chads and tyrones
because the risk of pregnancy would just
devastate their life not to say the
shame aspect wasn't there because it was
like the social consequences of you know
a man probably wouldn't marry you if 85
percent of women are virgins he's not
picking from the 15 that are not he's
like one body [__] right but but the
risk of pregnancy is like is was so
severe and so serious and like if you
first of all abortions were illegal so
like that wasn't an option and then the
reality was that like women had men they
probably were naturally more drawn
towards the more masculine etc etc but
it's like well that's a dangerous option
because that he might not commit so he
would pick a guy that would commit there
was value in the market it's a
commitment that value's gone today and
the numbers on it are pretty shocking if
you've got one match on Tinder as a man
you're in the top 50th percentile
50 percent of men never get a match on
dinner that's real data
if you've got 14 matches on Tinder as a
man you're 99th percentile
yeah so so should we all go back to the
1800s
well in some ways there probably
wouldn't be a bad thing and in some ways
there'd probably be some stuff you're
laughing but it's like not necessarily
bad right like well this is romantic hey
I would I would go back to like 400 BC
and I would go to like stoicism I'd go
to like Plato and Aurelius and to me
like that's a beautiful thing and you
can't disagree with that philosophy
right that just because it's old doesn't
mean it's Antiquated well and I guess
and the question is what's more what's
more important money or family and back
then they had intact families now almost
50 percent of births today are out of
wedlock half
like this this is the direction feminism
has led Society so I think we can tell
us about feminism and more about the
liberalization and commercialization of
sex so I do agree with you this is a big
problem but I'd say this is less about
feminism and more to do with people not
treating sex or something
a big part of feminism was pushing birth
control with which allowed women to do
that birth control my man it had very
little to do no no yes yes it is
a feminist
I couldn't believe it Margaret that did
you mean singer okay
no it's kind of feminist no she wasn't
she was a very anti-feminist very
vehemently anti-feminist because the
thing is
if she was in office
there's a bit confusion there's a big
confusion between feminism and careerism
because a woman can be very very career
focused without being feminist feminism
is specifically about liberating women
part but part of feminism is spending
your your primary reproductive years on
a career and not a family a big part of
yes a big part of feminism is breaking
up the family pushing policies that
break up the family yeah but actually
what it is it's more about this idea of
women are an oppressed social class by
patriarchal society and this confusion
is because the confusion comes when we
start saying that a woman having a
career I mean she's a feminist because
feminists
will use that as an argument
it's using your primary reproductive
years for for a career instead of a
family it's not to say you can never
have a career it's saying prioritizing
isn't it yeah I mean yeah yeah it's
about family before your career feminism
pushes career before your family I'd say
a mole pushes women against men
I mean it does that too yeah that's what
I feel was doing yeah your business
sounds really interesting as well if you
look but if you look at the um the birth
rate it's it's in it's um negative to
when women get more educated they have
less kids so it's like a direct
correlate like if you look at the like
the more educated a woman is the less
kids she has
so that's why I say it's part of
feminism because they wanted to like
they wanted to depopulate everybody they
wanted to stop people having families
more kids I'm right down to family unit
that's why I say I feel Margaret was
well she hated feminism because actually
she was very very she was married but
she was also a career woman that's the
point is that she hated feminism because
she was actually very Pro this idea of
meritocracy and individualism and I
completely agree with you by the way in
the sense that yes feminism did
contribute cut you off because you've
been doing it so long if everyone tries
to speak you cut them off so I think you
need to feel it feels like yeah but when
someone is trying to get the point
across let them speak and you can
respond everyone is going to get a
chance to speak please sorry my problems
uh it's because I'm stimulated that's
why
it's a very interesting one I wanna I
wanna
um kind of point to the dark horse in
the room you know like there's also a
problem with men a big problem right
like what is it 40 years ago so for the
last 40 years the average testosterone
levels and men have been declining by
one percent a year so we have 40 less
testosterone as men
uh you know per capita than our fathers
did which is frightening and and that's
not nothing you know it's like because I
think about it like okay I'm not gonna
tell a woman you know or women how to
behave that's not you know I'm not I
can't I don't have agency over that
maybe I have some ideas but like
nobody's gonna take that seriously but
but like as a man you know and I'm lucky
first of all that I was growing up like
20 years ago not now because today it's
like much worse but I saw it happening
20 years ago and so when I talked to
young dudes and I'm very passionate
about mentoring young men because a lot
of our company we have young women and
young men that we hire and a big part of
it is like
yes men are having a crappy deal right
now but a lot of women are having a
crappy deal too like men suck right now
like they do like I'm not saying like
I'm like you know I'm like Hercules
whatever like that's not the point
because I know I'm gonna get attacked
for saying man suck but yeah like the
average guy sucks I mean they've been
raised like women correct 50 years yes
they've been I mean it's from it's from
school no we see we see we see how it is
but it's like it's like there's a couple
things like number one like if your wife
is like making you do the dishes it's
because you're not making enough money
like I said this before and again like
men need to man up and learn how to do
hard things they don't want to do in
order to get results they want not the
methods they like because it's like
LeBron James's wife is like LeBron
you're never home to do the dishes it's
like that's never come up he's just like
get a maid get three Maids I don't care
right so I have a question so I I spoke
to some like housewives in the U.S
um and they were telling me you need
about sixty thousand dollars um to raise
like she raised four or five kids on 60k
a year um which I think equates to I
don't know like 70 80 in pounds it's
less it's like I said it's less forty
thousand but the way that she would do
it is she said her husband would work in
the city and commute but they would just
have a really low standard of living
right and and like they would just do
the hand-me-downs she would um like far
like they had chicken like they just
lived a very very frugal lifestyle so do
you think if a guy makes enough money to
live on like base basically a low
standard of living but still provide for
a family is it then on the women or the
men like does he still need to earn well
so that's an interesting question like
and my philosophy on this was just going
to offend everybody and I've said it on
the show before and then of course I Got
A Lash but it's like I retired my wife
she was and people were like and I said
this and it got taken out of context I'm
gonna contextualize it because I love
that let me see yeah wait so I'm saying
like I understand what you're saying
like so I'm saying you can retire your
wife at 60 000 a year in the US
so the the problem is not is not the
problem the problem is that man didn't
reach his potential that's the problem
it's like dude if you're raising a
family on sixty thousand dollars a year
you took some shortcuts and you took the
easy way as a man like I'm sorry I know
a lot of guys watching it they're not
making that money you can make more
money like it's a okay let's put it this
way is making money important to the
outcome of your life is it important to
the health of your family of course
especially in the states with the health
stuff right is it important to the uh
outcome of your children's future huge
like kids from higher income homes live
in better neighborhoods they go to
schools they get more connected they
have more opportunities in life and
you're like well I wasn't born a
millionaire well make sure your kids are
so I have another question when you
think of society as a whole There's jobs
that we need to have done that aren't
going to make a ton of money but we like
we need them in society like we need bus
drivers we need I know I know some of
these are gonna like vary the income but
like we need plumbers we need
electricians so when when I was uh like
when I was let me tell you something
this is really cool so when I was a
college student I went door-to-door
selling encycloped videos you know that
I did it for six years and eventually uh
once I gained some confidence and some
let's say you know vernacular Panache I
decided to knock on doors in wealthy
neighborhoods I'm talking about very
very rich like multi-million dollar
homes money I had never seen before I
was shocked to find out that I was
meeting a lot of plumbers
and I was meeting a lot of mechanics
these were like I was expecting all the
wealthy to be Dockers yeah that's a
permittal class but upper class like
high net worth and like upper upper
middle it's like 56 business owners so
so and what kind of businesses do they
run do they run like cigar businesses no
they do the crappy work nobody wants to
do yeah I had one of my wealthiest
clients Even in our company today he
runs a waste disposal business I'm not
talking about garbage he cleans up after
concerts you know those portable toilets
they bring in that's the that's what he
was doing in college just cleaning
toilets and he built a business out of
it right now of course you're going to
say that's not available to everybody
and that's scarcity thinking because
most people are inflicted with scarcity
thinking but you can actually educate
your mind as a man or a woman you can
educate your mind you can educate I mean
your dad's an entrepreneur it's given
you a crazy abundant thinking but I
guess I guess the way I think is like
even my dad's an entrepreneur but there
were people in his company that made
around the income we're talking about
yeah because your dad paid your Dad paid
them to stop pursuing
but I'm saying like they still like that
we still need those men like it's not
like at some point you still need men
that are doing the average jobs and so I
I don't know like so yeah I agree with
you so wait wait so I'm I'm asking you
like in that case like do we still have
this mindset of like you need to do more
when they're doing a job that we do need
inside I 100 agree with you I I'm just
coming out of the perspective like don't
be that man yeah like I'm sorry like
like if you're that man like don't like
my dad is that guy right like my dad is
almost 70 he's still working and the
same job he's been for 35 years even
more still the same drive to work he's
he's a mechanic he fixes motorhomes you
know and it's like it's fine we do need
those men but but I'm making an argument
to like to the men that are listening to
this is like guys don't like figure out
a way
um I have a great interview I filmed
with Eddie Hall and I think you should
put it on your channel because it's 20
minutes you know Eddie Hall World's
Strongest Man and uh I I asked them in
this interview like what were you like
at 18 he's like I bought my first house
at 18 I'm like what he goes I bought my
second house at 19. he's not old he's
like in his 30s right and he goes
because I watched my dad and he used
this line word for it he's like I
watched my dad be a lemming
you know suffering with dignity that
whole thing is like and I didn't want to
be like that and I knew that I wanted
out because I didn't want to live his
life so yes of course there's going to
be most men like that and most women Etc
and probably they have to make some
compromises in their life in order to
you know adjust their lifestyle and by
the way there's this whole BS that's
like Burke and my you know my
grandfather's age he could work a nine
to five job and uh buy a house it's like
yeah your granddad bought a house in a
city that didn't exist yet it's like who
he bought it in New York it's like two
generations ago New York was not New
York today it was the it was like it was
a hell it was gross in fact one
generation ago nobody wanted to live in
New York right so it's like yes you're a
grandfather bought a house on his income
because he took uh I guess the question
I have is like not everybody is going to
make a ton of money and I like I know on
an individual but I'm looking at it like
a society at a society point of view
like if we look at society as a whole
there's average jobs that people have to
fill in for in order for society to run
so if we want families to come together
I guess the question is should women be
more willing to go down in lifestyle or
should men make more money actually it
wouldn't happen like that you know what
would happen is if women and I'm not
saying women should do this but less
women you know like incomes like nominal
incomes got reduced when women entered
the workforce now we had twice as much
labor available so obviously the price
of Labor goes down right back before you
know back before the the feminist
revolutions it's like the cost of labor
was much higher so people made more
money because only half the workforce
was available right yeah well she was
because this is this is the House Wi-Fi
I was entered because I was genuinely
curious like how much money you need
because it's just as women we can't like
add or do anything like so so I was
curious like how much money do you
really need to like um to have like kids
at home and all that stuff and she she
was saying like when she started
um he was making 30k when we got married
and now he makes triple that we live to
Frugal homesteading lifestyle when the
kids were young and it was actually
really nice and peaceful so I don't know
like I think a lot of times we think
like we need to have a guy that like
makes a ton of money in order to have a
family and I just don't think it's well
what they say but part of that thinking
is girls nowadays can go on a date with
a guy who fly him to Dubai and dispose
them a week later so it's like girls are
experiencing lives that they can't sign
up for long term because they're
investing in a man's present not in a
man's future and you know why women used
to go to college before college now or
80 women and now you know but why did
women used to go to college yeah okay my
mom told me that she's like it's your
your Mrs degree your misses degree yeah
yeah but then I went to the school it
was like all women
yeah so right now right now universities
are 80 female and the men's rates are
dropping substantially but back in the
day I mean this is something that we
don't talk about now but I I knew about
this growing up it's like women went to
University to to find the man with a
successful future that's it's like
sounds offensive that's what they did so
I have a question
should a wife obey her husband Point
Blank period
yeah of course yes
yeah yeah
it depends what you mean by okay depends
what it is like what he says no no like
what he says goes Point Blank slowly if
it's a respectable relationship then
yeah in a relationship should definitely
be about complementarianism so in terms
of like should a man and a woman be
working together absolutely and I also
want to say as well I really like what
you said earlier regarding your business
about how your businesses are a
pro-women and pro it's not telling women
that you don't need a man it's saying
that you should be having higher
self-esteem and that's quite positive
absolutely
but yeah definitely women should I think
a big problem as well with feminism is a
lot of women have become very anti-men
and a lot of women are not appreciating
the things that men do in society this
is a big problem you know a lot of you
know men are doing most of the dangerous
jobs they're really not being treated
and being respected and that is a big
thing well I mean women are out there
like I saw that ebony something I forgot
that girl's name but there was a girl on
national TV said she wouldn't date a bus
driver
and so it's like women women yeah but
what what job is she doing what money
does she have that she can make a
statement like that she's I mean she's
39 regardless I mean what money does she
have oh yeah but this is so she she said
she's a man with certain money so she's
on TV but the problem is women like what
money because anyone could be on TV what
money has she got um I could actually
own anything like she got more than him
that she can say I don't want that guy I
mean yeah I mean she has more money but
my but the problem is men don't care
about your money no but my point is a
lot of women are saying they don't want
a guy because he's got this that hasn't
got that but what these women are saying
that need to understand is what have you
got to put on the table
it's all good saying that you don't want
a man because he's a bus driver but you
know well whatever
if you've got more than that man that
you can actually that gives you the
right to say I don't want to be that man
because of what he's saying you know
it's interesting like when you think
about it she's 39 she has no kids the
bus driver can still get a wife she
ain't got a man and kids yeah but that's
my information my whole point is like
who's the bigger loser like she was
stopping at him she's [__] I'm with
no man and no kids because of her
attitude yeah can I drop a bomb here I
wouldn't want my dog I have two
daughters I have two sons two daughters
I wouldn't want my daughters marrying a
bus driver
yeah but why not about that like because
I'll tell you why not but are you
training your daughters to be on a
standard and on a level that they can
talk like that yes there you go 100 yes
but do you have my point I do yeah
because how would you like it speaking
to Mike sorry how would you like it then
like if there's a woman that's hot doing
like what that comes and degrades you
then and says I don't want a guy that's
doing this or that yeah so do you get
what I mean and she imagines she hasn't
even got nothing look I understand I'm
taking a contrarian position because
like we should be like blah blah but no
listen guys like I'll just say it right
now I work too damn hard my entire life
to like to get my family out of poverty
and like literally you know we
immigrated like pronounces from the USSR
so I was living in social housing I grew
up in social housing right like I grew
up on like like legit Food Bank type
lifestyle and I work really really hard
for like my kids to not experience that
and obviously there's going to be some
entitlement when I talk about it like
there's some entitlement that comes from
them because they have things other kids
don't have right but that's what we want
but I worked I work too damn hard to set
my daughter up for a low standard and I
know that's gonna like piss off some
guys watching this but I work too damn
hard yeah they make like 80k like 80k in
New York you know great adk New York is
like poverty
I work my ass off so that
um well first of all one of the benefits
and again I'm gonna talk to the guys
watching what if he's young if he's like
one one of the benefits of working your
ass off is that you become more
sagacious you become more wise you start
to see patterns you start like it's not
the it's not the building and making
money and having the business that that
is the ultimate
cultivation of the thing you work for
it's the person you become your views
change your positions change your world
view changes right and that worldview
you want to try and it's like and if you
actually follow it you know they say
that wealth skips Generations that's not
true wealth actually tends to be fairly
intergenerational and only a only a
quarter of millionaires inherit their
wealth there's more millionaires being
made every day now than ever were nine
percent of American adults about one in
ten or millionaires you're gonna not
believe it but you're gonna google it
right now you're gonna be like oh my God
one out of nine American adults or
millionaire so there's constant wealth
being created right there's constant
wealth being created
um if my daughter is like hey
I want to marry a bus driver my thinking
is I don't think my daughter is growing
up in an environment where she's going
to find a lot of like stimulation and
that thought you know what I mean like
my daughter like she sees me every day
she sees what I'm doing every day she
comes to my office sometimes and sees
how people work and how things operate
she asks questions that I would not have
she's nine today she asked questions I
would not have asked like she would ask
me like she's like you know we went to
Dubai she's like Daddy Why did you put
an office in Dubai like specifically
there and I had to explain to her like
all this stuff and it's like one of
those things where it's like she doesn't
understand of it but like she starts to
pick up ideas right and and you can
prove that you know like I'll tell you
guys how you can prove like that making
yourself a better man makes your kids
make better decisions very simple
absolutely some some of the smartest
some of the best business people I've
ever met in my life were secretaries to
CEOs
because the whole time they're spending
their day around the CEO and so they're
seeing like decisions and high levels
like I see that with pearls like you
talk I'm like holy crap I think I asked
him is your dad like a massive business
owner you're like yeah he sold his
company I.T no because you don't talk in
a way that like 26 year olds talk like
I'm like that stuff you know that stuff
I wouldn't have known if I hadn't done
it and my kids are gonna see that
they're going to make different
decisions and like yeah you want to be
nice and virtue signal be like yeah like
go marry a bus driver it's like I work
really really hard for my daughter to
have higher Staff well and I think if
she gets married young that's like a
fair ask but it's like when you're 39
I'm looking for I'm looking for ambition
like no but I'm saying like the girl
that said that I was 39. looks like so
so so my father-in-law is a Swiss Train
heart surgeon like that's that's that's
a lot of like that's a lot of driving
intelligence right and when he met me I
was starting a freaking Suit Company
and I asked him if I could marry his
daughter
right and he said yes and I think about
that I'm like wow that's crazy because
at the time I'm like I'm starting a suit
company yuck you know he's just like and
he's just like great like I'm a heart
surgeon you know and he's like and I and
I build hospitals for NATO that's what
he does uh yeah
me I run a suit company oh the same
company
it's called lgfg lgfg we're gonna we're
gonna do a shoot reveal soon
suit
not suit
s garments
leather jacket I made this let me tell
you guys I made I made this I made this
jacket for Dan Lok and then very nice
jacket it's got Bruce Lee and whiskey
inside correct so I was starting a suit
company and I don't so I don't know if
he sawing me like a successful whatever
but he saw ambition and drive and a
serious commitment to achieving that
goal if he drives the bus great but I'm
gonna ask him like when are you planning
on buying that bus company uh yes and
this is what I agree with what he's
saying totally I agree with that I think
you you could I would agree if she's
young and attractive but that lady is
39. it's like you can't ask like at that
at that point and it's no like like I
don't know it's not that old it's it's
old for a family like it's something
it's one thing if you want to be like a
second wife but like to be the first
wife you know like how are you gonna
have kids at 39 you can't are you
married no would you like to get married
yes will you marry me no why not am I
the wrong gender
yeah how do you know I'm not how do you
know I'm not a man
you know I don't think she's taking you
back that's what he's talking about no
no what he was saying because even if my
daughter like I find it's important that
that guy's educating oh so I find it's
important that the guy's educated like
factors like that I do find it's
important like you said the ambition
it's all about the person's ambition
definitely I love India man I was in
India a couple months ago and we you
know we have some some great business
acquaintances there and they haven't
arranged marriage and it's crazy like I
talked to the dads that married their
daughters off and they're like yeah we
have to interview the guys interview
their family interview their friends we
went back to their best friend
Elementary School to see what kind of
man and I'm like did you ever turn a guy
down he's like yeah I'm like I'm told my
daughter you're not marrying that guy
why because you're gonna have a bad life
but Dad I love him yeah but in two years
they're gonna change your mind
I'm gonna I'm gonna Read Super chats for
a second and then King can you pull up
the the atom 22 video next
oh oh did you pick one or no from you
just just do the the tape one and then
um Second and then first do the like the
first one we reacted to okay Jeff boozy
Pearl do you ever do giveaways I believe
a scanner is impersonating you in the
comments on various videos yeah guys I'm
not gonna WhatsApp any of you so um if
there's someone putting my number that
is not me
um you are chatting to someone else d
Miller feminism is very toxic being
feminine is wonderful being feminine
works wonderfully and under the
direction of the masculine feminine is
directly in conflict with the feminine
and the masculine Dr David Baker I
realize he works in self-improvement but
don't say don't but he says don't be
that man wait these men keep the lights
on keep civilization from collapsing and
guard you while you sleep have some
respect D Miller feminism is very toxic
being feminine is wonderful being
feminine works wonderfully with and
under the direction of the masculine um
feminism is directly in conflict with
the feminine and masculine uh Vegas I've
never heard a multi-millionaire say that
they are say they he's a liar I don't
believe it a Justice for men and boys
Pearl if you didn't exist we we'd have
to invent you thank you for your work at
puffy Vegas he's lying and I know plenty
of multi-multi multi-millionaires have
never heard them say this once he's
lying I don't believe it words on your
mouth um you need to become rich it
comes up Google media to bring it puffy
Vega he's insane please answer puffy
Vegas I know multi multi-millionaires
I've never heard of this guy is he for
real I've never heard multi-mole
millionaires say any of these things um
gonga hey Pearl I've analyzed your
channel and what you have achieved is
phenomenal I'm proud of you kid um
congrats Doug MPA I'm a Dimitri Stan but
he's talking out of his ass a Trad woman
should marry and respect a man that
works in the sewers making 59 000 a year
Dr David Baker name a historical fact
about the scold's bride to Pearl to step
two oh oh the 470 000 views 45 000 likes
and a thousand aged comment step three
LOL
um The Honest a-hole bring back the
muzzle D Miller feminism is very toxic
but being feminine is wonderful being
feminine works wonderfully with and
under the direction of the masculine
feminism is directly in conflict with
the feminine and the masculine uh dma D
Miller feminism is very toxic being
feminism is wonderful being feminine
works wonderfully under the direction of
the masculine feminism is directly in
Conflict why don't people Super Chat the
same thing
um Dr David Baker oops she lost me again
with the whoredom rational
rationalizations
uh d d okay you you super chatted the
same thing like 10 times
um Dr David Baker um top of my
historians cap to orange hair respect
Intel wild going live with the Godfather
um are going live when The Godfather is
live is not showing proper respect Pearl
bend the knee uh Let me refresh it
really quick
um and then we'll play the video
okay um do do the original one of um
them talking about him like getting
cocked basically like them talking about
it originally
yeah him and his wife
um have you guys heard of adam22
from you okay yeah yeah this guy
had the audacity you know what I mean I
you know I'm a nice I like to think I'm
you know polite nice you know
accommodate so I came I I did an
interview with him like six months ago
now normally was he a serial killer no
no he wasn't no so six months ago I did
an interview with him and it went well I
had a great time I thought we were Pals
and then I see him talking on a podcast
about how I'm a misogynist so I don't
feel any remorse when I'm covering this
story so recently recently he was in the
news because he him and his wife
um do corn together they're corn stars
and normally they would just do corn
with the two of them he had said I could
never do corn with another guy
but recently
he pimped out his wife
yeah so he
yeah so he decided that
um his wife basically came to him and
was like
other men you know what I mean she was
talking they were bringing up like
swinging that sort of thing they're kind
of into the open stuff and so they
decided that she was gonna go have sex
with another man
what do you guys and this is them
talking about it so this is
pull the video up there we go
there we go oh do you have it King
and a lot of people seem to think that
it being him or it being a black dude
was the thing but what people don't know
is that when we were talking about it
there was a couple of different people
that were considering and it's not like
they were all black dudes
no there's there's only a few guys in
the industry who are like big on social
media very well known by like just right
when you look at them you know that guy
you know and I wanted my first scene to
be like you know a big scene and it's
worth mentioning that we did a tick tock
in Vegas back in January where and this
might have been like the first time we
ever even joked about it on camera but I
said to him doing a little Tick Tock I
said who's the hottest girl here and
then he like put his arm around you and
walked away with you and that I believe
has like 9 million views on Tick Tock
and that if we were trying to like
minimize the amount of people who were
suggesting that you do a scene with
another guy that was probably not the
best idea because that made everybody
want to talk about it right yeah he was
like the obvious choice I was like oh I
have to go with him this is what the
audience wants nine million views on
this video definitely so okay going into
it how did you feel okay so I didn't
really know that she was can happen
until the day before the shoot it all
happened so fast because in my head I
was like oh this is gonna be my debut
scene I'm gonna need like two months out
I'm gonna go hard in the gym I don't
know about the debut scene I mean I am a
human being right but like sorry
like everyone's talking about like it's
my first scene and obviously it's not my
first scene I've been doing this for
seven years with you but like my debut
scene with another man another man there
we go a different a different man a
different but equal but man right
everybody in the room is laughing just
in case anybody wants to know
but anyways in my head every girl does
this right you have a photo shoot you're
like I'm I'm preparing for my photo
shoot I'm gonna look good this this that
I had all this [__] in my head of like
what I was gonna do to prepare but for
me I'm I'm getting excited it's Saturday
and I'm about to play poker tournaments
on Sunday so I'm excited for that and
then Saturday morning we're going to get
breakfast and you're like hey Jason is
in town I might shoot that scene
tomorrow and I'm like huh okay yeah like
it was awkward my sister was there she's
like I don't want to be here for this
conversation okay and so yeah I don't
know continue I mean and then we I just
walked away I was like I think I'm gonna
shoot with Jason tomorrow and you were
like okay and I walked away I went to
wash the dishes or something and then I
come back and you're just like
no facial no kissing okay that was like
the extent of the conversation right
um and then I left the next day to do it
and you barely said bye to me because
you were playing poker I said bye I mean
I'm playing eight tables at the same
time I mean it's kind of hard but um and
then I'm so glad that I was doing
something that is like requiring of the
most cognitive load possible so it made
it kind of hard to think about it while
it was happening and then by the time
you got back home I'm like basically
like finishing up poker then so I didn't
really have a ton of room to think about
it while it was occurring which was nice
it was the best place for you to be for
sure because that is kind of my happy
place that I don't get to do very often
yeah yeah okay and so I was so nervous
like
Beyond nervous and I'm still now I'm
nervous that it's gonna come out because
I'm like I wonder if it showed in the
scene but
um I was there for a couple hours
getting hair and makeup or whatever and
then I had to go and get Jason and bring
him in and we had to take photos and we
just started taking pictures and I was
like stop like leave I have to take
pictures of myself I cannot take
pictures with you right now there was
like so
[Music]
giving me your blessing but my man's
like it's not cheating he's just like
trying to remind me he's like being my
like you know I had no girls with me to
like just cheer me on or anything he was
being my little you said something about
how your makeup artist or your your hair
person was like your uh your therapist
oh yeah yeah they were being my
therapist so you're like talking through
it with him like oh I feel terrible I'm
about to [__] cheat on Adam yeah I
was super super nervous I I don't know I
just felt really uncomfortable I mean I
told you that like when we were in
France last month we went to the club
and these guys were trying to dance with
me and I literally left the dance floor
and I sat on the couch by myself because
I felt so uncomfortable I didn't know
what to do and it felt like it was
cheating like even if I just bumped into
a guy dancing and here I am I have to
have sex with somebody and it's gonna be
filmed and put it online right so yeah
it was a lot it was really hard hard
yeah what was it what was hard the
nerves I don't know
so this is them talking about the scene
look at her face not white that's a bit
I'm a bit disturbed I'm gonna show you
guys one more one more so then she also
went on another stream with some other
like big streamers to talk about her
experience
yeah so pull this up
and your personal opinion okay what
should you before what do you perform
more uh the BBC or uh Mr uh husband over
here
that's why you put us in two different
rooms
exactly we could just be true be true
here guys truthful okay
um
I did enjoy uh Jason's new everything
new is interesting and fun but
uh what you made him leave look at that
I'm sorry I'm just trying to catch a
breath so wait did you choose Jason over
your husband
and although Adam is very exciting to me
like a new experience is always going to
be a little more interesting and
different and Adam could attest to that
like a lot of them we have are probably
a lot more fun than him just me on a
regular night right yeah yeah oh I had
fun with Jason but I still have a lot of
fun with my partner and I don't prefer
Jason's over Adam and your personal
opinion okay okay
before more uh yeah so what do you guys
think that's literally disgusting
that's actually disgusting I'm not gonna
lie
no I might see that disgusted that's
actually disgusting
what do you what do you think what do
you guys think
about what about the clip about the like
open open marriages her saying she
prefers I felt really bad for her
husband I thought that was a bit out of
order it's like women will lie with
makeup bbls and Botox but they can't
just lie and say that she liked her
husband better yeah I think like like we
should have thought that out like that
was not nice yeah
because
what the hell like
you're just in you're doing a bit too
much
that's a lot though I'm not gonna lie
that that was a lot did he like make her
like sleep is enough
are they like
so they have a daughter that's this guy
they have a daughter and
um she's like young they think they want
to have more kids yeah I know it's crazy
right and and they um
like basically she brought it up to him
but he agreed to it so he he told her
she could go oh she Austin yeah do you
know like my opinion on those kind of
interactions is the other person
the person that brings it up they wanna
um
reflect their infidelity into the
relationship so they kind of bring it up
and ask like it's just a fun thing
they're trying to do but really you just
want to cheat and yeah bring that into
your relationship
it's going to be multiple men I bet
she's going to start sleeping with a
couple more guys more videos Everyone's
gonna become normalized in their
relationship yeah yeah no that's
disgusting especially if they've got a
door would you say yeah yeah no your
normal influences yeah that is wild
what do you think Dimitri well I mean we
had a girl here right now on the edge of
the couch just like why does a woman's
sexual past matters that's why
like you marry a porn star you get a
porn star like oh but she's so good at
sex because she's had lots of experience
and she'll have more and it's like why
do men value Chastity well that might be
one reason right there
why do you cow while other people do if
they're marriages I don't care I'm not
I'm I was asked to comment on this I
have no business what people do in their
marriages they can do what they want I
don't care I can only speak for myself I
care because I think it affects children
I think a lot of people make selfish
decisions that affect kids later and I I
think if you want to do what you want in
your marriage fine but when there's
consequences for the kids and it's so
funny because they're all like oh the
kids will be fine like we'll wait till
they're older to tell them but it's like
you don't know that so now you're
playing with your kids Mental Health
well there are a couple that records
themselves publicly and puts it out
there so like we're dealing in a
different realm to start with that's not
a traditional realm but it's a pretty
good like you know it's a pretty good
consideration like you're not gonna
well how do I how do I put this politely
I don't think there's a way to say it
but like you're not gonna marry the
chick that's the best in bed like that's
not the metric that you put on your
checklist like ah she's got to be the
best sex I've ever had like like it
could be but probably that's not going
to be top of your list for a wife would
you say that in the past because for
example prostitution was very common in
the past and it was quite common for a
lot of men to have say a wife but then
also goes to a prostitute why would a
man who was in a sexually satisfying
marriage feel the need to go to a
prostitute do you think there could be
perhaps a correlation between say the
obsession with female Purity and will
say
um I don't know men's almost seen women
and how this could actually be quite
harmful because it almost divides women
into chattel you end up with the man
having his wife who is the good girl and
the prostitute he's a bad girl as
opposed to having both of the women in
one woman yeah so it's really
interesting like Australia introduced
pro-prostitution laws so what 30 years
ago something like that and one of the
most ridiculous outcomes of like
legalizing prostitution in Australia is
that the divorce rate like significantly
fell it felt like eight percent or
something it was like crazy right
and I don't know what that means like I
don't know if that insinuates that man
we're living in sexless marriages but
they want to be faithful to their wife I
don't really know what that means I can
only speak to my opinion right like I uh
but but but I'm in a unique situation
the sons that I've been married for over
10 years and openly my wife has never
refused sucks never like there's been
times where like congratulations she's
been tired she's been like exhausted and
but she but she was the one that kind of
came to me earlier in our relationship
she's like you know like I can never say
no to you because I understand that if I
do then I'm denying you a right in our
marriage like she would probably
identify as liberal but she's the most
conservative woman I've ever met and and
so for me there's never been a situation
where like
I would seek it out because I've never
been rejected in that way and it's like
just openly there it is
um
but but I would say this like I
I know like like if I was in a situation
where like that wasn't on the table I
probably would leave the marriage like I
would I would just be like look like I
and I've had the conversation like
obviously because we're married for a
long time there's a lot of communication
that's like look like there are I told
my wife up front things to expect from
me as a man
um and I was very upfront about it I
said look you're probably gonna get a
husband that's traveling at least 20 to
30 percent of the time
like we have offices now in 27 countries
so like uh and I travel significantly
less now than I did in my 30s in my 30s
I was on the road 80 of the time very
often I'd see her for two weekends a
month where I'd have to fly her into
whatever office I was at that week
um but I said you're I'm gonna be
working all the time like if you're one
of those girls that needs me every day
at home you're not gonna get that I'm
just not that guy I'm very ambitious
um I'm never gonna cook ever like I grew
up cooking because my parents both
worked and so I have to come home and
cook my French fries you know in the
oven I'm like I'm never ever gonna cook
I'm never gonna change a diaper hate me
or don't marry me I'm never gonna change
a diaper I will not do it like I will
work so so so hard so that I can
Outsource that labor or somebody else if
you don't want to do it but I'm never
gonna do it I'm never gonna clean we
have July 8th marked on our calendar
last year because I took the garbage out
it was my first time I've been married
for nine years at that point and I took
out the garbage because she asked me and
I'm like I just felt bad I'm like okay I
just feel bad because you're sober of
four kids right but I communicated those
up front
um and in return my wife communicated
things that were non-negotiable to her
and I think one of her non-negotiables
oddly enough is that she wanted her
husband she could obey and we talked
about that like should a woman obey her
husband that was her demand
um and so and I love that because it
puts the onus on me as a man and again
guys can agree or disagree
if you want to be respected and if you
want to be obeyed you need to be
respectable
and you need to be obeyable
right and that's that's on you like I
can't I got to 263 pounds five years ago
I was working a lot I was on the road I
was eating like crap and I looked at
myself in the mirror and I realized oh
I'm not respectable that's a that's a
fat dude and my wife didn't marry a fat
dude and I changed it because I made a
promise that I in order to be obeyed and
respect that I have to be respectful and
obeyable so there's there's some
personal accountability there right yeah
I'm quoting them that is Farrakhan he
says that um
when a guy starts taking money from a
woman he becomes her son
you know and I think based on what you
said about the
thing I think those sorry I think those
things do become a or pull it forward
yeah so that becomes a factor so even
back to when you said about the bus
driver thing
um
it's not that you know there's something
wrong with the guy like there's someone
for everyone out there
but it's just about the levels and your
expectancy you know and you know how do
you if I may I'm very fair with that I
would like I'll say it and it's going to
be controversial I don't care because
it's the truth yeah I would as a dad
like I'm a dad you know and it's like
and it's my job to teach my daughters to
behave like I'm sorry but like there's a
difference between women that grow up
without a father to women that grow up
with a father my girls are grown up with
a father but I'm also gonna ixnay my son
wanting to marry a fat woman I'm sorry
but no no no no it's a fair point listen
listen Sons I got two sons right have
some freaking self standards man like
like grow your value so you don't settle
for that and if your country's got 90 of
that like some countries do I want uh my
wife's Estonian she's not North American
we met in the states I'm from Canada but
she's Estonian it's like no I'm not
gonna let my son do that why not because
it's like have some damn self-respect
dude well but I was thinking even what
you're talking about the moment he
starts taking money from a woman like
it's you're supposed to have one bank
account anyway if we're gonna go back to
traditionalism like I like I think in my
grandparents generation the wives always
worked they just gave their paycheck to
their husband I was going to ask you
opinion on that actually because there's
something you said earlier I was gonna
ask you your opinion on um women that
are working to bring to the table as
well
like what's your opinion on that would
you say that they're not met good wives
would you say they're not traditional
I'd say the majority are bad wives that
work if I had to do like a balance of
probability some people you couldn't
really don't realize and say bad words
because you've got to remember some
people are in a situation where they
either have to work in their
relationship I don't think they're bad
wives because they're working they may
have to be single by no choice and they
have to I don't I don't think they're
bad wives because they're working that's
not why I think I think that generation
is bad wives because that generation did
not teach like like submission if you
ask most wives that from like
roughly like 35 to like 50 it's like the
worst generation of wives just across
the board they don't believe in
submission that's when like divorce
started happening like if you look at
like the 60 70 year olds they might have
separated but they stayed together I
think they're bad wives because the
majority put their career before their
before their family
not all not all and there are absolutely
good wives out there that don't fit into
that category but like across the board
we're all working or that oh we've that
are single because some women are single
because I haven't got a choice some
women are raising children on their own
because they haven't got a choice well
well nice it may be life circumstances
or something the percentage the
percentage of single moms the percentage
of single moms that are single because
of they're being widowed is like three
percent it's like it's just very low
right so I don't see why you pointed
that out no I'm just saying like because
but there is personal responsibility
women that's going through domestic
violence these women has had to maybe
leave their country for so many
different there's so many factors the
majority of domestic violence isn't real
like songs that talk about that they
just they just kind of throw accusations
at man most domestic violence is
initiated by women like all the study I
just like um interviewed a professor
about this um that like
so they super in-depth about the stuff
and how feminist basically ruined
Academia because they all just
infiltrate the colleges and like ruin
all the studies and then they what they
do is they change the definition of
abuse rape sexual sexual assault all
that [__] they switch it so like abuse
used to be a man's hitting the woman
right or the woman's hitting the man
vice versa but they actually switched to
the definition and I can't remember the
exact wording it's in it's in that book
somewhere so I could pull it up but what
they do is they assume that the men have
power the definition yeah the Duluth
model and so the problem and they
expanded the definition of abuse so they
would include coercive control Financial
control and I just know this from doing
hundreds and hundreds of shows you just
start to see like patterns of or
interviewing hundreds and hundreds of
people like women will say they were
abused and then I like I look into it
and I ask them more questions like I'll
give you an example one girl that was on
the show she said I was abused I said
okay what happened give me give me
specifics what exactly happened that
your ex-boyfriend was abusive she tells
me me well I wouldn't leave and he like
shoves me out of the house well you
wouldn't leave what'd you expect yeah
yeah
that's what I or I I another girl said
she was graped
um and so I asked what happened well
basically she switched her mind when it
came to sex because what they did with
the with the definition of uh grape is
it used to be like basically forced sex
they switched it to sex without consent
the problem with that is what is consent
it makes it very Broad and subjective
when you make things subjective and
that's the problem with abuse so how do
we know how common abuse is right now
the difference is in Family Court which
the majority of abuse claims are in
Family Court
um and that's where they've expanded the
definition of abuse you don't need
evidence it's it's basically on a
balance of probabilities we think it's
more likely that he did it than he did
it you only have to convince one judge
in Criminal Court you have a judge a
judge and a jury of your peers so you
have to convince a whole jury and
basically though in in Criminal Court
um in Family Court only 10 percent of
women actually filed police reports
so it's like the majority the majority
are just talking [__]
sorry well yeah and it's been a wave of
propaganda the last hundred years to
basically convince us that men are
abusive controlling all that [__] it's
it's just not true like I don't know a
single guy that wakes up and says I just
want to abuse some women today
and lesbian couples are also the highest
perpetrators of domestic violence and
you are absolutely right as well there's
a lot of women who lie about false rape
statistics I mean we obviously what's
really sad is it actually negates the
women who genuinely are abused because
all of the women who are sorry false
great statistics and all of the women
who are actually you know great to do
endure abuse are actually being done a
massive disservice by these women who
lie we look at the metoo movement for
example there are a lot of women who lie
too exaggerated and that is very sad for
the genuine legitimate victims but and
the problem too is that they go into the
car it's like a whole system they go
into the colleges and tell the women
that you are doing the right thing if
you report this of abuse if you abort
this great like if he pushes you he he
can like like I was thinking about this
they gave us a presentation in college
that basically says if you say no to sex
and then change your mind later or you
don't explicitly say yes you should go
to the police so they go and they tell
the women that the right thing to do is
to go to the police when there's a lack
of consent and it's like it's just
Madness they just they change the
definition of words that are as old as
time to convince us we're victims
foreign
open relationships if it's consensual if
both the male and the female have agreed
that there's going to be an open
relationship it's fine but if the
woman's say is then using that to then
go and sleep with multiple men that's
not good because what you're actually
doing is you're betraying the trust that
you've both created together because
personally I think you know regarding
open relationships polyamory you know
you do you as long as it's private as
long as it's not say oh you know as long
as it's a private thing people mind
their own business but when people are
doing it and it's actually not an
agreement that's when things become
fuzzy
um let's you want to show the video of
they brought the guy that she that she
like had sex with on the call
okay I'm gonna take this
oh hello look who it is Mr Jason love
how you doing man
what's good it was good uh we're just
doing a little podcast here and uh
figured that we would uh you know have a
little conversation with you to see
exactly how all this was for you as well
gosh cool cool that's why I chime didn't
catch y'all see what's up definitely so
is there what's the vibe like between
you guys anything I should know about
I don't think there's like a really Vibe
I think it's like a business thing but I
feel just very uncomfortable with this
right now
I feel obviously a little uncomfortable
can you tell him how nervous I was
like so nervous oh my God
I feel so wrong right now I feel so
wrong right now like it's just work okay
but a lot of people have like a cheating
fetish like I'm not gonna lie like I
feel like you do yeah cheating I've done
in the past was I'm a little bit turned
on by the fact that I was doing
something underhand or take take myself
out of it but like if you're [__] a
girl and you know she has a boyfriend
she's doing something wrong that is kind
of hot
you see he knows
it's kind of like the adrenaline the
adrenaline like I feel so guilty even if
I was The Other Woman okay so Jason give
me a genuine review how was it
you went like a number skill or just
like
numbers sounds like it could be hurtful
but if it's a high number sure like a
four
100 nine out of ten really nine out of
ten who's a ten
well obviously her oh well it was a nine
out of ten I never I never grasped the
entire ten before that's like you got to
leave room for something that could
possibly top the next one okay yeah I'll
take a nine then that's fair
um okay yeah so a lot of people want to
know uh I don't know just like if I
should feel diminished as a man as a
result of this like the cuck narrative
is very very strong I just want to get
your thoughts on that and if if how
people should think about that in in the
context of me being you know the the
silent third party and all this
well I don't know like if you look at it
in the business aspect then basically it
was just a job you know she's high up in
her ranks I'm high up in my ranks that's
true together obviously would make the
moves amounts of money so it's not so
much being a cook if you comfortable
with it y'all communicating the product
obviously she said y'all did so it's not
really a cooked situation it's more of
like two people coming and making an
understanding yeah you know so if you
cool with it then you know it is what it
is me personally I don't know if I have
enough in me to allow it but everyone's
different everyone have different levels
of probably say mental maturity well it
would be kind of weird for you to find a
dude bigger than you maybe they could
resurrect Andre the Giant or something
maybe you could get Brock Lesnar to come
through and cut it up for you but I mean
you're kind of like with the biggest
dude that I could think of I don't know
it's going to be tough for you to find a
bigger guy
like not just the size it's everything
that goes into it that makes it you know
definitely
Lena is just like shriveling up into a
ball right now I can see how
uncomfortable this is making it yes this
is making me very uncomfortable and I'm
glad that he's only you know on zoom and
not here right now do you think that
would be awkward yes also I feel like
I'd feel very a lot of sexual tension
and I felt like we would have to do a
scene if you guys were built here see
she's out of control now she's on a tear
yeah I've been known to have that effect
I apologize see all right now I'm gonna
have to really mind you next time you're
going to an adult event that he's gonna
be at right no but I would be turned on
if you were there oh yeah it's like
you're part of it
so you think that if me and you go out
to a party and we see him that there's a
chance that we'd all end up hooking up
after I don't know
oh
I don't I don't care
I get it in regardless damn that would
be yeah I could say that that would
probably kind of make me feel like I had
put a cap on this whole situation if we
all did it together wow maybe that is
the three-way that we should do because
that would be
pretty viral rather than just some
random guy right
yeah it would be crazy
as long as I'm not sitting in a chair
with my [__] arms right behind my
back or whatever you gotta hold the
camera for one shot all right so now I
gotta rewrite this group yeah what are
what do people need to know about Jason
love since like you're kind of I almost
feel like a large percentage maybe even
the majority of the photos that you're
going to be taking over the next year or
so you're gonna it's gonna be people
saying like you're the dude who [__]
Adam 22 his wife I don't know I mean I
know you get recognized all the time but
it's kind of an interesting scenario
that you're in now right
I got stopped on the street like four or
five times already yeah you can normally
yeah
and this awkward like watching the three
of them yeah that's so weird that's just
weird do you know anyone that's done an
open relationship
I do actually how did like was it on
both ends yeah it was on both ends but
it was just them type of people that it
was expected you know what I mean like
so when everybody started finding out
they're in an open relationship the
female sleeps with females and the guy
sleeps with girls it was like it wasn't
anything right it was just like oh are
they still together no they're not
they're not did it did they fight over
it at all or no
um yeah I think this started getting
like abusive between them
and then the female actually ended up
having a baby with another man that was
him
he just went left like it was just it
was just it was crazy you said you know
someone
oh yeah I've got a few friends who are
into the whole polyamorous thing I mean
there's definitely something magical
about just a man and a woman you know
showering
a um relationship bond with one another
but as I said earlier you know I think
the problem and you definitely mentioned
they'll sort of mentioned this about how
a big problem with open relationships
and polyamory is jealousy can really
cause issues and if people are not able
to work through that that's what can
actually end up tearing people apart and
some people make it work I suppose
do you know anyone that's made at work
like for more than 10 years
oh well I don't know any like most
people I know like around
in their 20s or 30s so what about you
you know anybody any open relationships
no put eight years as a standard that's
the average length of a marriage um I
mean I I knew somebody went out like
like 15 years ago that was in that kind
of relationship
and I really thought through that I mean
this is like you know long before I met
my wife and everything but like I really
thought through that and
I mean so I've thought through that and
I kind of realized that polyamory like
massively famous favors the female
right because when you take like imagine
a society where it's like one woman and
multiple men let's just go like to that
extreme what happens is the woman has
all the access to the sex because the
woman then chooses who she has sex with
because women control the the access to
the sex and on top of that the man none
of the men know the paternity like if
they sort of are like a similar tribe
let's say none of the men actually know
the paternity of the child so the woman
has access to the resources of all the
men plus the control over all the sex
and who gets it at what time and and
whatever right so when you open it up
that way you realize that like that
gives the woman all the power yeah and
that's what polyamory is because the
woman still controls all the sex and
then the paternity becomes a question of
you know question so what does the man
get out of that like he gets access to
women and sex it's like but most men
don't really have that access like yeah
the top 10 percent of guys have all the
access anyways right so there's no and
that and the man in that Echelon is not
going to commit to a woman in those
conditions I just wonder like why I've
said this already like why would he do
this he's got money he's not a bad
looking guy it's like why would you pick
to have your wife sleep with another
dude the funny thing is he said the same
thing a couple years ago if you look at
his old videos but I think it's like a
result of feminism in a way because
because I I really think it's a result
of feminism because feminism implies
were equal and and I don't think we're
equal I think men are above women I
think they're better at us and
everything yes why yeah because every
stat shows they are name something women
are better at
well it depends what you mean by men and
women are equal because we're equal in
the sense that we deserve respect but in
terms of our strengths for example
there's been studies that have shown
that women are typically better with say
empathy women are better with women are
more women are more likely to kill
newborns than the elderly
well women can only have abortions but
if you know even even just newborns I
mean it's estimated they killed a
quarter of their kids like 100 years ago
like this idea that women are more
empathetic it's like saying it's like
saying one per one party has a gun it's
not the women are more empathetic it's
that typically women are usually because
of the way the female brain is white or
more suited towards things like
cooperation that's where there's a
higher level of women in things like the
odds but that's sucks that's why I think
that women can only be great under the
authority of men because when we're on
our own we just don't do well well we
don't want to you know be like
undermining women I mean we can say that
women have strengths and men have
strengths as well no I'm saying like I
can't think of a way that women are
their best selves without men like I
think women say the same but men also
need women no some of there's you can
have examples of history of men that
have been great did advancements in
society and didn't they like they
avoided women so they could they could
um like I think Isaac Newton died a
virgin there's some really great events
I mean they but it's equal it's equal
value because Matt like you need a sperm
and an egg that's 50 50.
so there have been some societies for
example that were matriarchal that were
matrilineal in which there was a big
presence
then that stood the test of time well
not in the western for example like in
small tribes like for example in India
in China in fact in China there's still
a tribe I think it's called The massua
Tribe and you have this very kind of
female lad tribe and it's not really
reminisce because it's not it doesn't
stand the test of time though plus
keyword keywords small tribes they don't
Advance that's the point
well yeah because they keep the whole
society within the frame of the tribe so
it's not really the same but they don't
Advance that's the whole point so so
what I think I think that women women
genuinely are not the best versions of
themselves unless they're under the
authority of the men look at what
happens when we raise kids by ourselves
we suck as single moms yeah well look
what happens when we we try to start
companies ourselves it's like we can't
even I couldn't even do what I'm doing
without being in the in the building
that a man built it's like women cannot
be great without men but feminism tells
them that we should be equal to men and
so basically feminism is saying we are
equals when they are our superiors and I
think it translates into relationships
and now you have women thinking that
they should be leading relationships and
having an equal say but men men uh men
do better work when women are watching
that's been noted and studying yes it
has also as well boys as well in school
are much better when there are girls in
education that's actually not true
that's absolutely the opposite uh but
men perform better at sports when there
are female Spectators men give more
money to charity when they're women this
has been tested in fact like something
like 20 females on a working team
increases the performance of the team
but it really procreases the performance
of the males right so you also need
women for men to compete amongst
themselves to be selected and to be the
best version so none of the things you
mentioned actually build Society where
do women watching the men building the
buildings where are the women cheering
on the building come on we all work a
little harder when a girl is in the room
where do women you know I'm not making
that argument I'm not making I'm not
making that argument
you know to me like the way that I look
at the way that I looked at let's say I
sort of had to rationalize through this
again because you know as we grow up we
all have to like find our place in the
world like where we fit in and how the
world relates to us and I had to like
really think and understand like what
women represented for me I mean again
personal anecdotal thing but for me it's
like women were the feedback that were
sent by the universe or by whatever
higher power you believe in to tell me
how I'm doing in life you know women are
for a man like women women
let me finish that point I'm serious I'm
serious I'm serious because like if
you're a guy and women are not choosing
you like that's a problem and that's
your problem like it's your damn problem
if women are not choosing you right so
there's definitely a feedback mechanism
that women give to men and what women
are saying to a man all the time is like
here's how you're really doing man
here's how you really do it in society
here's how you rank amongst you know
women don't have realistic standards
today sure and and so I don't know I'm
not making this as a relative argument
saying on an absolute scale but no but
you're saying you're saying you're
saying today that women will tell you
how you're doing in life so but I'm
saying but I'm saying that argument
let me finish that argument might have
worked a hundred years ago but I'm
saying I don't think that works today
because women because women
um
it's like our standards are crazy high
we only sweat so you're telling me if we
only swipe five percent of the time on
dating apps 95 of men are not good
enough well so so the standards and I'm
not saying the standard is fair anymore
it's changed good enough used to be good
enough right good enough's not good
enough anymore now there's a more sort
of a binary look at this it's like
you're either in that top 10 or you're
damned right but the point is we cannot
have a function like I just don't like
[__] on the average man and I don't
I don't like saying like that they're
doing something wrong when we could not
have a society without them like I I
genuinely think we need to be thankful
for the average man and saying they're
not doing good enough because they have
an average oh no I'm not making that
argument no no but you're saying that
like women like will tell you if you're
doing good enough and like well good or
poor but therefore therefore women are
are the primary like they get to decide
what's good enough but I think it's men
I think men decide what's good enough
well I'm talking about like just and and
also women and women criticize like we
totally I mean there's a reason they put
a muzzle on this like I said all of it
all of everything you're saying is 100
son correct I'm just saying the outcome
of it today like yes back let's say a
hundred years ago more men would fit
into the category of being given some
positive feedback for their
contributions to life and Society
obviously right obviously today's
standards are skewed and and completely
like delusional obviously right
obviously I'm talking from my experience
growing up I had to think like why are
women treating me this way and and then
at some point I have to realize well if
every woman is treating me this way then
maybe I'm the problem I'm the lowest
common denominator in all of these
Expressions okay so no I agree with you
though the standards are are completely
who was it somebody said on your show
maybe it was Sterling Cooper that like a
woman has no a man has to work four
times harder to get a woman that's like
four times of lower quality than your
grandfather that's 100 cool but so my
whole point is that men and women aren't
equals I think men are our superiors and
I think right now we treat them in
society like we're equals when none of
women all the jobs we do we could not do
without men even when like like women
can be great why wives and mothers but I
think a woman's natural role is to be a
guy's help make whether that's in the
workforce whether that's in the house
like I I just think like women cannot be
the best versions of themselves unless
they're under the authority of a man
even even me with like running this like
my I've listened to my dad like 90 of
the time what he tells me to do I think
the point he makes about like women
being that as a really good most face of
a man is good but also saying that men
are superior to women really negates all
of the qualities that women bring
because I personally think that women
should learn to have more responsibility
and I think this is a problem that
feminism brings it doesn't make women
have responsibility actually undermines
women because it turns women into
victims it says that we're victims of
the patriarchy rather than teaching
women to recognize our innate feminine
power and if we look at the power of
women you know women do have a level of
raw power it's just a power it's not
it's not saying but it's not it's not
safe it's not saying that we don't have
power it's not saying that we don't have
great qualities it's just saying I I
think that men in general are superior I
cannot I cannot find one thing that is
evidence based that women are better at
than men I was going to say beauty
pageants but that was proven wrong
recently well I it apparently well you
You could argue monetizing Beauty but
usually the only way you can monetize
beauty is through things that men made
the men run the industries men run the
infrastructure like if women left the
workforce tomorrow men would be okay men
even raise better children there's some
well men perhaps are needed to raise
children for certain relationships but
women are certainly better at raising
children and before you interject I'm
not I'm not making the argument for
single mothers at all I'm saying that
like so let me explain something so I
was can I can I ask you a question so
why do you think that when the data
shows that single father homes turn out
better than single mother home I agree
data definitely shows definitely so why
would we but I'll tell you what so so I
was doing some research for the book I'm
writing and
um I was looking into the gender pay Gap
right and of course like women make 76
cents a dollar of the man I'm like oh
that's interesting and I started looking
into more multivariate analysis and more
like actual academic studies not just
some angry raging feminists writing
about things they don't like and I
learned the highest paid subgroup within
any subgroup were lesbians they make way
more money than anybody else I'm like oh
that's interesting right well they have
some other disagreeable etc etc but then
I looked at one other study and then I
kind of followed the trail and it said
that once you introduce working hours
into the working relationship like men
out work women on average 160 hours a
month and 99 of the gender wage Gap can
be expressed because of the fact that
men simply way out work women and then I
looked at myself I'm like I'm a worker
right like I'm high conscientious High
disagreeable so I work work work work
work all the time and like I can handle
inordinate amounts of stress in my
business that like most people think is
insane and then I look at my wife right
and we got four kids and they're nine
and down nine seven I guess four and two
and it's Insanity at home and it really
only takes me about 20 minutes of a
screaming household of kids before I'm
like I'm going outside to sit on the
porch and smoke a cigar I can't put up
with this but the patience that my wife
exhibits with children and I understood
something right there's a natural
ability for me to participate paid an
act strong in my War which is my
business but there's a significant
natural inclination for her to be able
to put up with children she's under your
Authority though correct but that's
that's the whole point well she's just
better women but no but my whole point
is women are not the best versions of
ourselves unless we're under a man's
Authority we could very easily say for
example in India it's rather common
actually and this is very common in
Asian societies as well in fact
emotional Muslim societies for the man
to defer to his wife in fact this is how
it always was and actually you could
turn around and say well actually men
need their wives they need to almost the
factors is that in their home is that
the the man does what he does to care
for his wife and you could say that is
the power of the feminine that is the
man the first his wife the man does what
he does to love and care for his wife so
this brings it back to the idea that men
are not Superior to women men and women
need each other because as opposed to I
think I think men are superior to women
I think they're because every everything
like because
but we can't like I'm so tired of
hearing women say like because we're a
godsend because we have kids dogs have
kids okay are we do we do we worship
dogs do we say the dogs are so no come
on so so the the kid part is equal we
need an egg we need a sperm giving birth
equal equal equal equal because and if
you think about it men can impregnate a
bunch of women women can only carry one
child so in a way like what what what's
really more yeah but a man doesn't go
through the nine months of carrying a
baby that's a lot it is
a child is a lot but my but my whole
point is it's still equally do we need
the sperm and the Egg equally yes or no
because it takes two people
the woman still carries a lot more if
there's Harry and the baby for nine
months okay she has to deal with a
sickness she has to deal with
um the pains and what's the man actually
doing it I should be working through
that time okay what's what's harder to
give birth or to raise a kid why would
you want to believe that Menace you know
what I don't know because I haven't
given birth but from that speaking to my
friends I think
given birth is a lot like labor and
everything is crazy like they've come
out of it
I would argue 18 years is worse than a
day like that's that's what I would
argue but like why do we have to have
this gut reaction like oh it's a bad
thing if there are superiors we are your
bosses
the power of the feminine again your
boss is your Superior does that mean you
hate your boss
you're you're when you when you talk to
a police officer you listen to them
because you look at them as well we've
just listed ways in which men are not
Superior it's a woman and like no you
haven't you haven't yes you haven't
listed anyway you haven't no you have
children
you think about childbirth is you you
say childbirth as if it's the woman yeah
she carries the child for nine months
but she the womb is literally just an
incubation chamber life doesn't start
until the sperm
makes contact with the egg so without
the sperm the woman cannot create life
that's one two you said women are way
better at men than men that had given
birth and that's only because men don't
give birth and even the whole um issue
of giving birth women are failing at
that because the the the birth rate is
dropping so even the thing that women
are meant to be better at they're still
failing at doing that so that's the
point
well the idea is that we shouldn't
really say that men are superior to
women because then you end up happening
it's not about shouldn't say but it's
not about shouldn't say is it true no
like what no but what so men pay 80 of
the taxes 45 percent of men are involved
in the infrastructure women only only
seven percent of women are involved in
the infrastructure and most of their
jobs still aren't needed so so men Bay's
single mother homes Affair far worse
than single father homes my whole point
is not that women are not needed it's
not that women are not important but
it's that men are superior I gotta I
gotta I gotta try to poke holes in this
argument just for fun this isn't this is
actually it's interesting Pro because
you know you have some positions that
are viscerally like are going to cause
some reactions but when you get into it
you're like huh you know like some some
arguments are kind of worth pushing to
the extreme and I enjoy that uh women
smell better
100 of the time women smell better can
we give them that we also look better
that's also true women are definitely
more beautiful
women today have to wear makeup no no no
they love women King the reason I didn't
say women look better is because a man
just won Miss nothing 170 pounds I'm
actually a man just one minute right and
the average chick is 100 but they smell
better really because why not no listen
one out of three has an STD do they I
can't smell that can you sniff out STDs
no I've had a lot
I I'm telling you that that is a common
complaint I get on the show from guys
the STD thing one out of three women as
an STD
I I I I haven't been participating in
that long time but I'll say again but
women do smell better come on just give
them that one thing just put it on your
Twitter women
okay comments what do you guys think you
have to have some super chats it's not
even it's not even to be mean to women I
say women are the best versions of
ourselves under the authority of amazing
very easily say men of the best versions
of ourselves where the woman compliments
no I don't think it's the same because
it's going to make you come to Georgia
I'll give you an example George
Washington he's one of one of the best
presidents in all of history in the
United States he had no kids there's
very great oh he had kids come on
genetic testing proof he had plenty of
kids the last time I checked but I mean
yeah
I mean you're just arguing to like you
know there's men in history of course
that have had no children that have been
very great that we still talk about to
this day
I don't know listen I'm I'm literally
Playing devil's advocate because it's
interesting right like I like pushing
arguments to their extreme yeah another
one thing I'm noticing now like you know
I have
um grandparents that have been passing
away over the last few years and I'm
noticing that women like daughters are
just better for caring for the elderly
well then then but then why are they
more likely to kill them which one women
are more likely to kill the elderly and
to work with them probably they have to
spend a lot of time with them
elderly
mean why you know like there's even
there's even studies that show women are
less empathetic than like this whole
idea it's just feminism
it's not truly it's based on looking at
women and men's different neurological
women are more empathetic because
they're more agreeable and empathy
ability are like women are in general
I'm not saying there's like outliers I'm
not saying that's good or bad they're
just saying they're not towards men men
are more empathetic to them than women
yes because feminism is actually really
reduced the level of empathy that a lot
of women have towards men and a lot of
the the kind of kind caring gentleness
that women used to have is almost okay
explain this why didn't wanna why why
are women more likely to kill their
infants if they're more empathetic have
you spent any time with infants no I'm
serious if women wait wait wait if we
ideas women are nurturing and empathetic
why are we more likely to kill our info
like I literally have been for months
thinking about well they're also more
likely to raise the infants yes and also
because the mothers spend more time with
the children it's not because women are
more like that before that was the same
it was the same women killed 25 percent
of their kids because historically
because they're the ones who are around
them all no but I'm saying even when men
would get primary custody and there's
two parents in the home and so you could
say it's again if women are more
nurturing and empathetic and men are the
aggressive ones like why are the women
killing me we could say that women are
out there is a man because without a
woman a man has no purpose in life
because a lot of what men do is to on
the love care and respect of women a lot
of men doing their work why you were
talking earlier about men becoming
millionaires why do men feel that job to
become them
obviously yes you're right everything a
man does ultimately is to obtain like
the love and respect of women that's
literally what motivates us biologically
to acquire resources but that doesn't
actually challenge anything Pearl said
well it does because effects Vamps are
making the argument that you could say
that women are more Superior to men in
the sense that if it wasn't for women
men would have no purpose and that level
of I don't drive that gives the man's
life a purpose is to have a woman I
don't I don't agree with that I I think
there are met there are men that have
written like I can't I wish I could
remember this guy's name but he he did a
[__] ton of inventions
oh and you're thinking of Tesla problems
no no I'm not this was like a hundred
years ago and then there was one that
was like um and there was one that was
like Isaac Newton they would hide from
their wives so they could like invent
things it was asexual right it wasn't
Isaac new I don't remember the names but
I know there have been men in history
where it's like they literally chose to
stay away but then you look at it but
then you look at open and you look at
Oppenheimer you look at Einstein
completely the opposite like serial
womanizer but my whole my whole point is
I think the idea that men would just do
nothing if women disappeared tomorrow I
don't think that's true no I wish not
because when I've spoken to a lot of my
male friends they do say that
females are distracted just a big
distraction for them so they will stay
away in order to I don't know work more
in order to do certain things so in that
term I do agree like I I think it's just
a way for women to take credit for a man
the reality is the most successful men
have had to go through a period of
drought where they had no women so this
idea of it's women that men need women
to do stuff is just not true and if you
check up if you look at most of the
billionaires how many of them have have
a woman with them the reality is I would
agree that men do things for women but
you guys are saying men do things to
have a woman no men do things to have
women that's the reality sure well
seeing the men do things on the love
respects and attention of women a woman
though you said a woman well yes
actually a woman because for example a
lot of men were like well segment Freud
was you know he was okay whatever he was
but he was loudly a lot of men would be
in a very obsessed with obtaining the
love of one woman heck look at the story
of The Great Gatsby I mean Jay Gatsby he
puts on all of these parties oh he does
it all for a woman a very selfish
spoiled woman that is why you call
propaganda you're not a master yeah
we don't do things just because we're
looking for one perfect woman yeah it's
Society that's conditioned us to have to
stick to one woman that doesn't sound
very romantic well it's not romantic
because biology is not romantic that
doesn't mean that it's not an Envy it
doesn't mean that it's not an admirable
goal to shoot for like I I actually King
I totally agree with you right like you
build yourself into a powerful man that
you have options to choose from and then
and then you make the decision to commit
to a woman and this is where again I'm
gonna lose some people or you should
have as many trucks as possible no you
should become dangerous to be able to
have as many trucks as possible so that
your girl damn respects you and doesn't
cheat on you because once she knows you
have no other options she's damn leaving
right
um but but there's still something
admirable and respectful to remove
yourself from that Marketplace once you
have a woman that bears children for you
because it keeps Society civil right uh
societies where you have a man with many
wives they have a tendency and actually
a very predictable tendency to
um devolve into Civil War right so
there's a sort of ownership you have a
certain debt to society as a man that if
you are a highly successful man with
sexual options that once you choose a
woman you stay with that woman I have a
question since men build the
infrastructure so they run all of
society they make it run since they pay
the majority the taxes men pay like 75
80 of the taxes and women consume most
of the social services by the way yeah
since women are the majority on benefits
so basically we live in a man's world
the only reason we can do what we do is
because of men we're only protected the
police are mostly men the firemen are
men they're people that built this
building are men the people that
invented this microphone are men since
men run Society
are women indebted to them to give them
children as a group
as like a because what if men are going
to build this Society keep us safe are
women indebted to them to have kids what
do you mean by indebted like should
like should it should women be forced to
have children
how forced not not that Force but like
birth control band no you can't work
like if it gets too far to the point
we're not replacing like like we're not
fixing the birth rate should women
should there be policies that come in
and and bring bring it back so birth
control to me is almost like social
media
um like you know when we when we when we
invented like Society invented and
adopted
social media I think we looked at it as
a way to stay connected a way to to you
know be more socially robust and to have
more meaningful deep and connected
relationships and actually social media
has been profoundly negative and so you
know social media consumption is all
about like Hedonism narcissism
um and and the birth control pill is
sort of like and I'm not saying this
because I'm anti-w whatever like I just
been looking at Stats and what the birth
control pill has done it's just been
resoundingly unpredictable like it's
just not what people thought would
happen right like it's first of all it's
led to fundamentally changing who women
are attracted to
which is like destroying families
because then women go off birth control
and they're not attracted to their
freaking husband anymore when one in
three women has had an abortion so it's
like we'd have a replacement birth rate
if women would stop killing their kids
so they're so yeah to answer your
question like you know because you asked
the Roman Force well I would I would
reframe that in probably the most
offensive way I could possibly reframe
it which is like if an an apologies to
everybody it's about to write negative
things but like if you're a woman and
you go through life without having kids
I don't care how empowered you are you
pretty much biologically failed as as
your own species yeah like what is the
purpose of your life if like you are
what millions of years of reproductive
success and evolution and you're the
person that ends that chain forever like
that's pretty narcissistic I think sorry
quick question Paul where are you
getting these stats from because to my
knowledge in the UK it's only around
four percent of people that actually
have STDs so I'm not sure you're getting
these stats about one in three women
having STDs and three women having
abortions I mean it's a very minority of
people I said have had well it's a very
short but it's sort of it's actually a
minority of people if you've actually
got that from the CDC what's that it's
like the Center for Disease Control in
America okay so the Americans start then
well I know in the UK it's only around
roughly four percent of people have
actually had an STD it's quite a small
it's quite a minority of people it's not
like how do you know that from from what
from what and where do you get your own
stuff from I looked at that on the NHS
I don't believe the NHS but the problem
as well
sensationalism because usually when you
look at these stats they'll use
sensationalism but it's actually a small
minority of people who actually do these
kind of things you know it's not like
everybody has this I mean they have said
actually that apparently some like 80 of
people have at least one STD but it's so
it's like a non-dangerous one
effectively wow I think the men are like
wow I'm so happy that it's a
non-dangerous STD well men and women
sensationalism also what's this not on
the amount of men that have an STD I I
the amount of men that have an STD well
one out of three men are virgins
at what age under 30.
well again this isn't this is that's
that's accurate one out of three men are
basically inside how does it help people
to see these stats as well because
actually it's almost like selling this
image of like it's like if you look at
the news it's all the shock value you
know what I mean like how does that
actually no because it's honest it
creates a real picture and I think I
think you just say like women just don't
like the numbers when they make the US
look bad and like when I'm sorry as a
group when 90 like as a group I'm not
saying every woman but we can't say
these numbers make us look good average
age of first marriage is 31. there are
some studies that say women admit to
sleeping with seven Partners a year in
college and there's other studies that
say our partner count is between five
and eight but regardless we're [__]
than we've ever been we we are fatter
than we've ever been the average weight
is 170 pound 90 percent of women have
been on birth control which [__] up
your hormones it's like this just is the
market and we also say there's more
women now who are more well educated for
example men don't care and honestly the
education education
education is just literally a way to
suck Us in to learn [__] because I
was actually in school maybe like what
four or five years ago and
nothing I learned I use in this day and
age at all everything that I know now
I've had to teach myself yeah it's it's
literally
it puts in America and it's worse
actually I would say argue because women
make less money than men but we're in
more debt we own two-thirds of student
debt well that's actually why colleges
wanted that because they wanted more
people and more debt right now yeah it's
pretty it's pretty scary once you start
digging into affirmative action and
understanding who's being exploited
really through that you know and it's
just like a push for more and more debt
yeah yeah like when you ask who owns the
colleges and why they're pushing stupid
useless Majors when you said that like
oh everything I learned in school I
never had to use it it's like that's not
just for women that's for men too like
unless you're going to be an engineer a
lawyer or a doctor you have no freaking
reason but men are more logical so
they're like ah we're not doing this
we're gonna go yeah they just go
straight into the women are like oh get
my gender studies sociology degree so I
can argue with pearl Europe a lot of the
leading female politicians right now
women like you have Marine Le Pen in
France you've got the lady in I think
Serbia you've got um what's her face
Maloney do you think Europe's going in a
good direction actually oh it's doing
much better than the UK because they're
starting to move away from all of this
six you know how long was your female
prime minister in power for here like
four days well Margaret Thatcher was
yeah but you're going back like you're
going back two generations and I love
Margaret Thatcher that whole generation
of women was an entirely different
generation of female leaders right these
were conservative like Union bustling
Margaret Thatcher you know Golden Bear
those kind of women were a different
breed right like your prime minister
came in and she was well she was we're
gonna go to China and enter the pig
markets and oh yeah four days later like
get out right but I wasn't talking about
her
European politicians yeah but like look
at look at the finished uh Santa Marin
was just kicked out and everybody was
like how misogynistic to kick her out
it's like really she was number three in
the election and number two was another
woman that beat her uh Arden in New
Zealand was just booted out it's like
there's only a misandristic laws all
through Europe like we just talked about
how how open these laws how open
missandry is like rampant in the law
well what was referring to effectively
for example if you've got France right
they've got this male the current prime
minister as a guy well that's not really
the point the point is is that
effectively you've got all of these
women like Maloney Le Pen who are coming
in to sort out all of this you know
globalists very far left nonsense and
they are the globalist far left ones no
Marine Le Pen is the woman okay women
are more likely to wage war they took
the last 500 years the women that were
in power were far more likely to wage
Wars
started by man I mean well but women are
more likely to wage war because they
have no incentive to not because they're
not they're going to be the ones
fighting there's no skin in the game
well there's been much more male
politicians so you could actually turn
around and say well actually men and
more later in the world and the world is
more peaceful when men are in power it's
not very peaceful right now it's my
percentage it's not by the number of men
well and it's hardly peaceful now it's
more peaceful how is it a lot of Fosters
you have the woman Le Pen who's sticking
up against all of this nonsense if you
look at the state of France now with
this you know what's just happened
recently in Paris
and speaking out against that and not
just her but there's a lot of you know
as I mentioned Maloney
women women vote for these far-left
policies the politicians are accusing
the women women I don't I don't know how
but like women always go to the
individual when I'm talking about the
collective I'm talking about the group
women vote far more left than met in the
U.S we would have won every election
conservatives would have won every
election the last hundred years had
women not voted
well I wasn't talking about that I was
talking about the conservative
libertarian female policies no no but
you but you'll bring up individual women
and when I tell because it doesn't it
doesn't show the group there are always
outliers there's always there's always
exception so women are more likely to
wage war and it makes sense why right
because conservatives by definition are
those that conserve the existing
Institutions and who build the existing
institutions
well what about the fact
the fact was started by men for example
things like the Crusades or with World
War one and World War II that was all
men so women are still more likely to
wage war when they're in power well
what's an example women have always like
I can't think of that okay I'll give you
one Catherine the Great captures Crimea
uh on behalf of Russia and we seem to be
having a border conflict in Crimea today
but then I could just as easy say well
World War World War II caused by men but
that entire Castle it's a per capita
argument obviously it's not an absolute
let's add it all together obviously over
the course of history there have been
more Wars as an absolute Starter by men
but what Pearl is saying is that female
leaders as a outcome of their leadership
there's a statistical significance to
more likely having a war when women are
in the lead it's just there have been
less females obviously there's been less
war started by females of course what
about the women who are trying to bring
peace what about them there's guys
trying to be in peace too who cares but
the problem is when women try to bring
peace we naturally go to more
egalitarianism as opposed to hierarchy
men naturally put themselves in a
hierarchy where women it's like why I
did a show on [__] the other day I was
like what's a hoe what's a [__] what's a
[__] and women will naturally be like
well we can't label them we can nobody's
that were men it's like okay sex
attention money go and it's like they
naturally just do do a hierarchy
because because the problem is
egalitarianism doesn't work in society
that's why we have this like like
everyone is special every like that's
where you get a lot of the left policies
they come from egalitarianism we are all
confusing uh Marxism with Classical
liberalism because Classical liberalism
has got nothing to do with this left no
I I'm saying like so so for example
let's be fair and equal let's let the
men into the women's bathrooms that
that's an example of how women want
things to be more fair
but that's my point is women tend to
vote more left when it comes to cultural
I think again you're conflating left
with liberal because for example no no
I'm talking about left in the U.S so
more liberal so like left like um so I
guess you might you might say
um I don't know the feminists
women tend to be more feminist women you
know this is true this is just common
sense look in front of your eyes like
we've come away there's more crazy
blue-haired feminists that are girls
than boys there's more there's more
women and even like the policies being
pushed just look at the what's going on
in divorce court like this isn't pushed
by men it's pushed by women or men that
are catering to women because they can't
win elections without the female vote
well again it depends on what you mean
by egalitarian for example like if we
look at say the the principles of
Classical liberalism which is not a
English liberalism is really an English
idea it's that for example everybody
should be treated as equal under the law
and what that means is that men and
women should both receive an equal
amount of respect and the problem is
that the feminist idea has got nothing
to do with liberalism it's rooted in
Marxism it's rooting this idea of that
you know we should have as you said
earlier the destruction of family the
destruction of society it's this idea of
women aren't a press social class and I
do agree with you that a lot of the
problems that have come to women come
from feminism but I do thinking
but it's also saying feminists also
promote that we are equal which goes
back to egalitarianism well it actually
you could say feminists are promoting
Female Supremacy I mean I mean you true
that's true but that's how they promote
it right they say we are equal but we
are not equal to men which again it goes
back to egalitarianism fairness so when
women are in politics we tend to vote
for those policies you know damn well it
is not men that are pushing the trans
stuff in the bathrooms and I can tell
you this being an athlete playing with
this stuff the men think this [__] is
stupid well the women well I mean Posey
Parker JK tell you they don't they don't
they don't sleep but you keep you keep
talking about individuals I'm talking
about the group you're naming people I
don't know I'm not from Britain so so I
don't even know who you're talking about
Posey Paul comes but at my point my
point is that across the board women are
voting for these far left policies
like that this isn't even arguable man
I'm not the ones um pushing
participation trophies in schools that's
women
so it's a minority of women and
feminists make up the minority
statistically speaking most women don't
identify as feminism they don't identify
as feminists but they still behave like
ones when you when you average age of
first marriage okay because feminists
want you to do a career first family
later average age of first marriage is
31. that's a feminist that's not it's
just because they don't identify it was
one they still move like one no because
it's like okay what do you define as a
feminist I I'm saying they're still
following a feminist world but what is
your fault what do you define a feminist
worldview the thing the thing is she
keeps using the original meanings of
what these words were meant to mean but
the reality of the world we live in is
like families have come in and change
the meaning of all these things they've
taken over everything for instance the
rainbow never used to have anything to
do with being gay
dietary never used to be a left thing
this is a fashion statement that's my
point but the rainbow never you started
having to do with your sexual
orientation but they came over took that
over and now it's the whole lgbtq thing
it's the same thing with participation
trophies all these things were never
there until feminism came in on so the
point is whether they say they are
feminist or whether the original meaning
of feminism was something different the
reality is their actions all aligned
towards what is happening right now so
that's the problem you can say you're
not a feminist but if you're acting like
a feminist you are a feminist what is a
feminist act like
you just you just keep going in no I'm
asking you what does a feminist act like
we've said it over and over again no but
you're really because it's almost like
you're creating these two extremities
yeah we have explained it so many we've
explained it like 10 times on the show
feminist is putting a career before
family about traditional women put
Family First the actual people
you cannot change the definition because
you feel like it well no the actual
definition
okay we have enough
all right um I'm I'm gonna close out the
show so we're gonna do final thoughts
um let me I'm gonna Read Super chats
then we'll do final thoughts okay
all right guys make sure you like the
video and subscribe to the channel okay
um Brenda has a baby when a man asks you
a question red you need to answer before
you continue to speech speak Dr David
Baker it's roughly one in three women
have had an STD admittedly including HPV
and with the record setting epidemic
levels of chlamydia and gonorrhea and
herpes the rate is roughly the same in
the UK as the U.S I'm 93 Tope most
women-led countries are in flames right
now I'm FS Claire the stat said that 96
of women are amazing great if it says
eighty percent of women initiate divorce
they say where's the source what did he
do thank you Google for men who don't
need to show off their only need for
women for nurturing um
for men who don't need to show off they
only need women for nurturing preparing
food keeping the house in order anything
more provided by the woman is just an
added Advantage thank you Google men
don't need women to be successful we can
equally we can work easily and be
successful at it it's just our boosts
our egos it makes us fear feel powerful
when we have more women than the other
guy it's always a competition for men
puffy Vegas T essler was in love with a
bird and was never married puffy Vegas
George Washington had six kids and
they're all black I could be wrong but
let me know 90 free-toe pie I'm there
afraid of their mothers that's why they
can't admit that men are better than
women empathy who matches to delete
their kids Dr David Baker I would like
one example they give of women being
better at something than men giving
birth they choose the one thing we can't
actually test D Miller I'm from the
perspective of being a trained Midwife
acupuncturist practitioner and neuropath
my wife has had five home births all
delivered by me all in less than two
hours labor she's said she has very low
pain
Vinnie pressure makes pearls put that on
the mug keep on cooking these oyster
critics and naysayers remain unfaze
you're doing great you're right Mendes
said the worth of men um it doesn't
matter what women think especially 20 23
women 90 free-toe pie name this richest
strongest and smartest woman Lil yachty
and I will name the male counterpart
that will supersede them Bar None Dr
David Barker a masu tribe in China is
exaggerated and how
matriarchal it is they stay subjective
to the authority of fathers and brothers
and sleep with random men and control
the nightly visits all STDs and STDs are
rampant the honest a-hole um this dude
hates poor people 90 free to apply
please read my last Super chat whenever
someone opposes generalities and say
some people don't do acts tell them to
name names or be quiet like an adult
puffy Vegas I live in Vegas and I
believe that 7-Eleven should women
cannot be FF I'm 80 percent of my male
friends wives children's adult females
hit on me and I don't believe women can
be faithful
puffy Vegas where what is your podcast
it's called the pregame D Miller um
feminism is very toxic being feminine is
wonderful being feminine works
wonderfully with and under the direction
of masculine my point feminism is
directly in conflict with our feminism
is directly in conflict with the
feminine and the masculine 90 free to
buy if everyone is making money then
who's going to make your stupid socks
Dimitri how's it going Lil yachty enter
black dragon the problem with Dimitri's
argument is he's completely [__] on
hard-working men that make Society run
my father is a bus driver with 19 kids
money doesn't make you a better man or a
woman uh Let me refresh this really
quick
also guys make sure you like the video
the like is the most important metric
um Dr David Baker and the 21st and 20th
Century Classical liberalism liberalism
was absorbed by the white right-wing
women or by the right wing women who
vote left aren't voting for Classical
liberalism Brenda has a baby-ish when a
man asks you a question okay
um all right let's do final thoughts and
then just tell the people where they can
find you starting here and then go
around
very interesting discussion thank you
for listening my name is Zarina Macho
and I have a YouTube channel called the
rational female where I discuss
anti-feminism and if I may um go ahead
and plug my novel it's called
Tic-tac-toe and it basically depicts a
society which has run rampant with um
feminism and uh it's a pixological
conclusion of cultural Marxist feminist
Society it's called tic-tac-toe um yeah
you can check it out it's basically uh
depicting The Logical conclusion of all
this work nonsense
um thank you for having me once again
it's been an interesting topic today
that we've been speaking about and what
show were you on last time I was on I
recognized your voice I was like you
know what we actually started talking
about Andrew Tay oh that was the show
you're on I couldn't remember that one
and it was about five other people okay
that was the one but
um
yeah it's been an interesting
conversation and you guys can find me on
Instagram free underscores
full stop
r-a-z-z and my business page smile Hub
if anybody wants their teeth white and
[Laughter]
I can't see when they start going yellow
go ahead Dimitri yeah uh I'm gonna just
speak directly to those super comments
thank you for commenting and donating
your money to Pearl to get your voice
heard that's great
um
somebody said this dude hates poor
people yeah hey you're right no I do I
do you're right I freaking do
you I do I hate listen there's a lot I
hate rich people well let me be the
emphasis I hate poor people there it is
it's on the internet I said it I hate
poor people and I'll tell you why I hate
poor people because I grew up poor and I
hated being poor and that version of
myself I didn't like that life and so if
you think that I look at poverty in this
day yes I do and I grew up in that and I
know poverty more than 95 percent of
people that are well let's put it this
way most people on this chat have never
gone to the food bank and felt the
embarrassment of having friends at your
house knowing that you have food from
the food bank I felt that growing up yes
I hate poor people and I didn't like
myself when I was poor so I I changed it
number two is like you don't like the
hard-working middle class men that are
keeping Society afloat my dad is a
hard-working lower middle class man he's
in his late 60s he fixes cars and
motorhomes for a living and
um
he is that guy I don't hate them I just
don't think there's any virtue in
suffering even if you're suffering with
dignity to suffer is not virtue you are
still damn suffering and that's why I'm
here guys uh the reason I come on this
show is to promote my company lgfg
fashion house it's lgfg like look good
feel good actually the name of my
company is when you look good you feel
good when you feel good you play good
and when you play good they pay you good
that's a Dion Sanders quote and he made
me a suit that's right we're gonna check
it out after this
um our company here's what we do guys
we're in the custom clothing business we
sell suits and shirts and related
apparel to high net worth people you
know people that buy Custom Tailoring
their High net worth but what we really
do is we teach young people
how to sell how to build a business
through sales and how to build their
lives through having a career in sales
there's only really two ways to make a
lot of money in businesses you sell
something or you own a company and if
you own a company you're selling
something a product or service so that's
what I'm here for check out lgevg.com uh
you can find me on Instagram lgfg
Dimitri or LG underscore CEO underscore
Dimitri I have two accounts and I hope
that you um are ambitious and hungry and
you want to get more out of life than
just being a bus driver when you're
middle age I think it's a sad existence
I don't want you to be a lemming
um Pearl teaches us about the virtues of
of society today I teach people how to
make money in our company and you've had
people on our show from our company
that's what I do they still say we still
like Dimitri they said in the chat they
said I'll take but we like Dimitri I
still I still hate poor people okay
um all right guys make sure you like the
video on your way out and subscribe to
the channel
um also also sign up for our Google form
we're going to do meetups in London and
in the US so if you want to be a part of
those I know I've been gaslighting you
guys for a couple months but we're
actually going to try to do one either
end of this month or early next month so
make sure you sign up and we might have
old shogatz guests come on we've got so
many musicians we might do people like
performing I don't know we'll see like
the video on your